Let's move it over. So, this is the clip. Dan finally tells the
Liykan story. So, if you guys remember this, Dan talked about
telling this Lykan story. And if you were watching the stream
when I saw it,
I talked
I talked about how like this was just bizarre to me that he would
bring this up cuz I knew what it was. And it was like totally
unprofessional of them to like be talking about it in group chats
such that I heard about it. Like I knew exactly what it was.
I also heard different details than what Dan gave here. the one
about why Lykan got fired. It's a little bit like that, right?
And I was just like, dude, you're going to look like a total
psychopath when Lykan doesn't say anything bad about you and
you just like leak random details about how you guys ended up
not working with him anymore. Like that's it just seems bizarre.
It's just weird to me, right?
I have no idea why he would do it at
Yeah, it's very it's very weird. It's just it's just odd. Okay.
It's just odd.
Did Lykan really do that stuff though? Do some do that stuff?
Oh, hold on. We'll go through and we'll see what he talks about.
I guess I have to I didn't even watch the whole clip. I just
watched a little bit of it.
So, I heard different details.
People still watch that dog podcast. No, they don't really. Um
I don't unless I'm missing something. I think the numbers were
not that great,
which you know that sucks. If that's the case, maybe it's good.
They probably get the DG embeds, right? I'm guessing
maybe it's doing better.
It didn't seem like it did that great before. Yeah. I don't know.
Is this This is like the
like the the I'm sure they can do better, right? I'm sure they'll
do better at some point, but like the the numbers are
that they are. Anyway,
so Dan told this apparently he's trying to get some DJs back,
so he's going to attack Lykan. It's very strange.
Let's give it a listen.
So, are you talking about Lykan or something tourniquet
or you talking about like Dan or something? Okay, cool.
>> let's check this out.
as you know, for the early episodes of anything else, we had
Ly in there. And >> how many episodes?
>> I don't know, like the first 10 or something. The first
20.
I don't feel too bad about sharing any of this dirt right now
because I feel like he's kind of done a lot to not be good for
people. Uh either willingly
or unwillingly or something. So he's kind of done a lot to not
be good for people. The does that even mean? How are you going
to soft pedal an anti-semitism allegation and not have any idea
why you're making it? Actually make an allegation. You
This is the most behavior on the planet Earth, right? I'm just
going to vaguely allege that he's anti-semitic without saying
anything.
Are you serious?
Yeah. I I hope Putin feels awkward. It's It's an insane thing
to do. It's a totally insane thing to do, right? To just go,
"Oh, well, I I feel like he's not been the best friend to people."
It's like cuz he likes Palestine.
He thinks cuz he thinks, "Hey, by the way, just remember that
Lyken spiritually in essence won every debate retroactively when
he's the person saying, I don't think we should trust Israel.
I think they're going to do a lot more damage than they they
claim to do or want to do. They're going to like actually destroy
this region." Right? That's that was Lykan's overall point was,
"Hey, we can't trust these people. Th this is going to go very
badly. This is going to be way worse than you think." Lyken is
right in retrospect. even if he couldn't argue it, even if his
like reasons weren't articulated well, he actually just won completely
given that Israel has actually ethnically cleansed all of Gaza
has like killed tens of thousands of people.
So I as much as Dan will say, "Oh, he's not been the best friend
of the No, he was just correct. He was correct."
All right. And if you're going to make an allegation like this,
you better make an actual allegation. Dan doesn't do it because
Dan is a coward and he knows that people if he actually tries
to give a reason, he will be wrong cuz he's a lazy coward and
he will not actually say what's bothering him. He won't actually
make points. At best, he might see this clip and go and ask somebody
else to make points for him so he could recite those points later.
They'll still be wrong. They'll still be easily defeatable, but
he will he'll never do it himself. He just wants to vaguely assert
this, right? Is complete. Anyway, that was the first thing that
I immediately watched this and I'm like, this is total garbage.
I don't know why you would do this when Lyken doesn't like attack
Dan. He's never gone after Dan,
right? It's it's so weird to like
it it's just the most bizarre thing to do to go on and just like
blow like it up and say, "Oh, well, I you know, I feel like I
I'll talk about this cuz he's anti-semitic. Shut the up thing."
I I I don't know. Like he's pushed a lot of stuff. So, I would
say the first thing is that he was very bad at his job. Um, that
should be apparent to anyone that was there. And it was kind
of like to the point where he was supposed to be, you know, how
you guys all kind of like [__] at the idea that like
um like Destiny, why don't you get a tech guy? Why don't you
get someone who does this, the audio video guy? And it's like
we did. We tried like Lykan was going to be the guy that was
going to do that. And it was >> Hold on. Was that Now,
correct me if I'm wrong. Did you guys mistake Lyken for an audiovisisual
expert or were you explicitly extending him some time to figure
that [__] out? Right. I my impression because I'm
not a complete [__] was that Lyken didn't know a
lot about this stuff and that he was helping and that you guys
asked him for that help and he was trying to learn on the fly.
That was my understanding. If you thought he was an expert in
this, you are a total Okay, as a first point.
Now, did was the audio video setup was the audio of anything
else good in the first couple episodes? No. I remember several
hiccups. Was the audio of anything else good after Lyen was gone?
No. I remember it being dog. Essentially, the entire show, they
had issues the entire time. For any part of anything else that
I ever watched, they had issues with Lyken, without Liyken. It
seems like Lyken wasn't critical to them having repeat issues
with the audio and visual
>> Just a show to the point now Steve can't trust anyone.
until he has to do it all himself. Right. So, we had that. So,
he was doing sound effects. Uh, >> yes. From what I understand,
Destiny couldn't stop with audio settings.
If I remember correctly, Destiny couldn't stop [__]
with audio settings,
which I listen, that's his that's his thing he can do. Now, unlike
Unlike, I would say probably if you're the person managing all
of this, you need to figure out a way to make sure your settings
get preserved. you maybe need to do like I I don't know like
some kind of version control would be my my first thought is
like you could set your OBS settings maybe some of your like
mixer settings in some kind of version control and you could
make sure that you would revert back to them, right? You could
record and record what the settings were when you last had things
set up so that you could easily revert back to them if you had
to.
You know what I'm saying? So, but in any case, that's what's
on him. But, but there were challenges and
and it's like Destiny and Dan who presented those challenges.
Yeah, hold on. I know Zanakali, but you need to follow it yourself
so that you can roll back to whatever your settings are, right?
>> And he was doing production and nothing was working
and it was getting so bad. And um the show was always me and
me and uh Steve had ownership of the show and that was it. And
um it was getting bad towards the end to the point where we were
getting like pretty
annoyed um and we're like how are we going to handle this because
we've known this guy forever. we've known him literally forever.
How the are we going to like, you know, how are we going to possibly
like get rid of this guy without it being like a a drama and
everything else like that? And we're thinking, we're thinking
and we're thinking and um
at any point did you think, hey, maybe we should go talk to him
and say this is unacceptable cuz he's our employee and our friend
and we should show some respect to him as a human being. Did
that thought cross your mind?
Hey, hey, Lyken. This is like unacceptable. we can't continue
in this way. You're our friend, but holy, like this is we need
to figure something out now. And then you could have that conversation,
see what he's saying, right? See what he thinks.
At what point did you go, "Oh, hey, uh, I should I should like
try to, you know, treat this person with respect. I should try
to treat them like a human being and talk to them." You know,
as we're, you know, we're thinking over a course of like, you
know, a week or two weeks, something like that. Lykan comes up
to us prior to this, while we're thinking about how do we get
rid of this? He's like, "Hey guys, can I get uh I think you wanted
a third ownership in the show." And
uh by the way, I heard about this. That's not what I heard when
when it was brought up to me. Now, I got that secondhand from
somebody that they were gossiping to in like a group chat or
something, but when it was brought up to me, it was not 30%.
And Dan saying 30%, certainly maybe, maybe, hey, maybe I heard
wrong from the person who told me, but I heard it was more like
10 or 20%. Okay.
which I understand people probably think that's a lot, but I
have a reason I think that's totally reasonable.
Um, and we can go into it maybe after the clip, but I that's
not what I heard. So, I I challenged Dan on that. Was it really
30%, are you sure about that? Are you sure it was 30%, cuz it's
weird that I was told something else. >> Me and Steve are
like, "We have to get back to you on this. Um, we got to think
about, you know, what what we want to >> Dan said, "Uh,
I think it was." Which tells me he's lying on purpose.
He's like trying to increase the story to make like it look worse
for no
>> Uh and how how we're going to handle it and everything
else. Um and then
so
there was >> how much was he getting paid?
>> I'm not I'm not going to like >> Okay. Okay.
>> Yeah. We don't want to go into how much he's getting
paid. Do you know why we don't want to go into how much he's
getting paid? Cuz Dan pays dog. If Dan had any say in how much
like he was getting paid, it was nothing. Okay, Dan pays his
employees and he brags about and and he loads himself for paying
slave wages. That's he literally lods himself for this. Okay,
now that's possibly it's possible that Leica was getting paid
by like Destiny or possibly even Arerudite because of how the
studio was set up and maybe like it wasn't getting slave wages.
Okay. But I know if Dan had any say, I think this is why Dan
didn't want him. I think Dan was upset with how the balance sheet
for the show looked.
I think he didn't like paying like him for the show. >> That
type of doesn't matter. >> Um, so
finally
me and Steve, we came up with an idea. Press play.
>> This moment came to us and we realized the only way
to get rid of Lyken was for Lyken to fire himself. The way that
he would have to fire himself was that we would have a guest
come all the way. >> This is, by the way, this idea this
like
there's like double you you double up the layers of like psychopath
here in that he's like, "Yeah, we should totally like try to
sigh off this guy into quitting." And then not only do you not
realize that that is totally psychopathic,
you think it's like cool to go and tell this story about it where
you are basically going, "Yeah, I'm a completely like amoral
psychopath.
Yeah, I want to sign up this guy into quitting because I'm too
scared. I'm too cowardly to go and say, "Hey, this isn't going
well. You need to pick it up or we're we're going to split down
to do a show with us." It would be a big guest. They spent a
lot of their own money. And when they spent that money, okay,
everything would go wrong. We planned for it. We were thinking,
"Okay, how do we do it? Do we with the the audio settings on
the computer and he wouldn't be able to figure it out?" And we
would blame him. We're like, "Okay, we'll handle it next time."
Hutch comes on the show. We're like, you know, guess what? He
did it himself. He did it himself. He actually it over. We didn't
have to do anything at all. He literally the whole thing up and
we didn't even have to sabotage the computer. He sabotaged it
himself. But we were in there. We were talking about
>> uh that's that's literally not what I've seen from tweets.
He says market wages BBB gun market wages. What does that even
mean? >> Whole thing up and we didn't even have to sabotage
the computer. He sabotaged it himself. But we were in there.
We were talking about we're going to go in there and we're going
to set No, he'll never know to look if you go with the recording
quality and change it from CD down to telephone quality. Who
would think to look there? No one. We had all this planned this
deep thing. There was multiple people getting consulted all of
this stuff. We're doing it and then Hutch came on and he just
he just it up all by himself without us having to do anything
at all. It was like the most amazing thing. I remember after
the show >> this is by the way this is like their friend
of multiple years. this is their friend of multiple years that
instead of just going and saying, "Hey, this is like unacceptable.
We need to figure this out now." They're like, "Oh, we're going
to plan how to sabotage him." And he tells this story like gleefully,
totally gleefully.
And then he's like, "Oh, thank God we didn't have to do it cuz
Lyan made another mistake." Which, by the way, I'm pretty confident
I remember that Hutch episode like it was saying, "Steve, what
did you come down and change?" Like literally, they had it working
and then a whole bunch of was changed.
Oh, like even during the show, we should have been upset because
Hutch was sitting there waiting to go live for a hour. Okay,
we're sitting there literally he's it up and I'm looking at Destiny
the whole time. We should have been helping like you know out
me and him me and Destiny. I How is How is Mr. Button not saying
something here? Like does Mr. Moot realize that this is you?
That they don't care about you? That they wouldn't go to your
wedding? Like you you're the loser here. You are literally Lykan.
How do you not How do you not see that? that you are literally
liking. They don't like you. They don't care about you. They
don't think anything good about you. You're just somebody who's
useful in the moment. What? What's >> They're looking at
each other and we're
>> "We did it, man. Me and Mark Rutoo, we did it. We didn't
even have to do anything. We have complete plausible deniability.
We didn't touch anything. He's just so stupid. He himself. We
didn't even have to sabotage him. This dumb bastard sabotaged
himself.
That was it. And then finally after two hours of sitting there
waiting
completely finally the show started and we only got in our hour
with Hutch and that was it. And he was so embarrassed afterwards
that he was basically like listen I'm I'm sorry. I think you
know Yeah. So that was that was the show. Oh god. That was a
good one. >> Was it was it a good one? Was that a good
one?
I don't know.
I
I can't imagine.
Yeah, I It's like actually crazy, right? Like he's desperate
to not work a real Oh, no, no, no. Sorry. This one, Marma, dude.
It's just mean-spirited losers who revel in this kind of [__]
Yeah, it's like total
This is like totally antisocial behavior. This is like insane.
Was Mutin hitting the bottle hard in this one? I have no idea.
This is like
is bizarre behavior.
It's It's so weird.
And honestly, it's one of those things that doubles up for me
where it's like it's one, it's already like fairly despicable
behavior when I know about it. I know that they were like memeing
on this guy like behind closed doors cuz despite him being their
friend, I already knew that it was like bad. But then to not
be able to identify that you look like a total psychopath telling
the story is also just bizarre to me. Like remember when we totally
didn't tell our friend that he was like up enough that we were
thinking about firing him? Remember when we pushed that to the
point being so avoidant that like we we were just we're thinking
about how we could avoid a conflict by making him quit by trying
to sabotage things.
Remember
remember and also complaining about I guess the 30% that asked
for in the show. It's not what I heard. I heard it was more like
10 20. Okay. I'd heard multiple things but I never heard 30.
I heard 20 at one point. I heard 10 at one point. Okay, if he
asked for 10, that is totally reasonable. I'm sorry. And the
reason it's totally reasonable is that Lyken has worked in like
the software industry. He has like job experience. He can't go
back to the workforce.
How do I know that it's not just more profitable for Lyken, more
long-term success for Lykan just going back to the workforce?
He could have easily said, "Hey guys, um, I want to keep doing
this, but it's actually like economically I think I have to go
back and try this other thing." And like I have to go back to
the workforce. And if if you want me to stay, I would need this.
I would need like this 10 20% or maybe even 30. I don't think
so, but maybe even 30, right? He didn't work for free. He definitely
got paid as well. So I I just think that's totally reasonable.
I think it's like, hey, I see potential in this show. I want
to stay, but I need some like stake in the show to stay. I can't
stay for a salary because the salary in the real world is always
going to be better. So could could I like get some kind of steak
in the show? That makes total sense to me. That makes complete
sense. Yeah. And one it gets like li like and more invested.
It's this is the downside of positive thinking black magic. When
it doesn't work, it really doesn't work because you have to cut
off all ability to process negative stimulus. For every Trump
there are thousand homeless people yelling at clouds. And Dan
is one of the homeless people yelling at clouds. Yeah. Anyway,
I it's just like to me it's if Lyan has earning potential in
another field and he's like, "Oh, well, you know, I thought there
was going to be something here with being a cook and I would
make something work and maybe that's not going to work. I'll
probably just go back to the normal workforce. you know, I'll
work a software job or something. And if you want me to stay,
I would probably need some kind of stake here to if we build
if we build this up, we could make it like good and I I could
earn a real living and this could be something I could retire
on, right? I want a long-term game plan.
That's what makes sense to me. Well, I think he was like in some
kind of management even less. And he was in sales at one point
as well for for some company. I think he talked about working
for a printer company. So, I don't know how much he would have
made. I I honestly don't know, but it's probably just more than
like being part-time chef, part-time podcast guy, part-time whatever,
right? And there's like possibly like growth there with no growth
at these companies. I don't know if he can I don't know if he
can just keep working here, right?
Yeah. Like's like so dumb. He totally thought he was building
something with his friends, but actually he was working with
two like totally amoral psychopaths who had no concern for him
on any personal level and were just looking to like either farm
him for content or use him for as their gopher for as long as
he would accept it. Like
I I don't know how this doesn't for the people who watch this
and who think like Dan's a normal person or a or a good person.
I don't know how you can watch this and not see just a totally
like disgusting skinwalker.
I
It's so
It's so bizarre.
It's so bizarre that you would go and do this to me.
And by the way, I guess I understand people who are like, "Oh,
like wanted 30% when things were going so badly." Like, if that
were true, I would understand that feeling, right? You don't
want to give a huge stake in something to somebody you feel like
isn't doing their job. But then what you should say is I don't
think you've earned that even remotely and I I love you. We're
friends but you have not earned that and I'm not giving that
to you without like major improvements. I need to see improvements,
right? You have to have some investment in the other direction.
What they wanted was to give money to this guy so that they could
off and not have to do anything, right? They wanted to pay him
like like a totally faceless employee. You you take stuff off
my plate and if you don't take stuff off my plate, you Lyen was
like, oh, we're friends, so I'm going to try to make this easier
for you guys. I'm going to try to help, right? I'm going to try
to learn all this stuff. I'm going to try to learn to be a podcast
producer. I'm going to try to learn all the audio. Oh, I didn't
even mention that like the audio issues. I think in large part,
if I remember correctly, didn't Destiny buy like a NASA mixer?
Like it was some NASA hardware with like a thousand inputs and
outputs that was like professional grade and you had to have
a PhD in audio engineering to understand.
Isn't that why Destiny up the audio for the election stream so
badly? Isn't that why the audio for the show was infamously bad
long after Lyan left?
And so they wanted this guy who had no stake in the show, who
was just getting paid some salary to have all of these solutions
and not I I'm guessing not even a particularly good salary given
Dan wouldn't say it, right? He had literal professional audio
engineers in his ear and he bought the hardware. They then ignored
the recommendations. Oh, there you go. Like it's And then they
come and they blow up like it. It's like, dude, we all watched
the show. WE ALL SAW YOU GUYS DO WORK after liking left. The
camera stuff was fine, but one, you get stuck with with where
you needed a producer. You get stuck for like minutes. You had
total dead air for like minutes while you guys try to figure
out some Discord or anything else, right?
So, you had all of that and you had tons of audio issues the
whole time, forever. Anyway, I I just think it's goofy. I think
it's I think it's goofy to bring this up. Oh, the other thing
I didn't bring up as well was like they were trying to build
towards some kind of like multi-tenant space, right? I don't
know if you guys remember there was like a Bridges podcast hosting.
Does this site still up? This site is still up. So, they had
like Bridges Studio Rentals, right? Bridges Studio Rentals. They've
got Bridges Studio. They've got anything else? Our shows. These
are the shows that operate out of Bridges Studio. I give people
>> There's Liking Cooks. I was cool with Elijah. Anything
else? There's whatever the [__] this is. Bridges.
Some Bridges
>> This is also Lykan. Okay. All right. Did I miss the
first one or Oh, no. Is this the Bridges podcast? Okay. Got it.
Got it. So, they had this and you could go and look at pricing.
So, they were trying to build up this space so they could rent
it to other people. And I'm guessing they weren't like paying
enough for this to properly get done either. But this meant that
they had multiple cup podcasts running out of the same area with
the same like hardware connections that could easily be up if
somebody wanted to go change them around and experiment which
from my understanding Destiny did all the time. Like Dan Dan
knows that he had to yell at Destiny that he screamed at Destiny
for with the audio when they had guests coming the next day,
right? That they had didn't they have a whole fight? Isn't that
what like the Ranton stuff happened over like when Ranton went
there everything was late and then the audio didn't work or something?
I'm trying to think but I I've watched all these fights happen.
I don't remember. I blocked out a lot of those a lot of that
content in my mind. Okay. But I remember all of this like happening
over time. So you have multiple people who try to run podcasts
out of this area. It's not that by the way it's not that they
had other podcasts. I think it was just Aerodite and then the
Anything else podcast and then maybe whatever Destiny was using
it for. But like
they they had obviously some issues. They hadn't figured out
how to share this space and not have the changes with things.
And so they were trying to build something complicated and they
didn't invest anywhere near what they needed to to make that
work correctly. And that was just put on Lykan. And again, I
don't know what Leica was being paid. I have no doubt that him
wanting like a a stake in some of these things makes total sense.
And none of them wanted that. And
and even listen, I don't even have a problem with none of them
wanting that. I don't have a problem with all of them going,
"Actually, I don't think Lykan's good enough at this to give
him a steak. I don't think Lyan's good enough at any element
here to give a mistake. I've got no problem with that. But don't
don't take your friend and then try to embarrass him after the
fact, right? That is that was your friend. You were already pieces
of to him as far as like the entire process went. Why do you
got to go out months later and try to embarrass him? Like I could
honestly deal with all the other stuff. I obviously never leaked
any of this. It seemed pretty gross to me. I never leaked any
of it cuz I was like whatever. I like it's it's not coming out
and it could just be buried and I don't care. And then Dan started
talking about it like I'm going to tell this story like it's
a funny or cool story and it's not. It's just a weird totally
antiso antisocial like lizard story like you don't think other
people are humans.
It's so bizarre. Yeah. Yeah. I'm starting to understand why Dan
has this campaign against.
It's like to make up for a total lack of social connection,
right? Like that is what it is. It seems like to me like Dan's
incapable of forming human connections and so he just wants to
attack Hassan and and go after him all the time.
Whatever. Whatever. Gross. But it is what it is.
It's so bizarre, dude. It's just like it's And again, I I can
agree. Hey, you don't want to give this guy the the money or
the the stake in the show. But again, you were talking about
him such that I heard about it, right, as a uninvolved like third
party. So what? You weren't keeping it under wraps. You're clearly
putting in some group chat somewhere and then not only that,
you're like teasing it after the fact and you're like continuing
to call this guy anti-semitic. There's like so many things totally
wrong here that make no sense. Anyway, I'm going to start repeating
myself so we can move on. We'll read some of the comments. That's
why you don't hire a cook to do podcast production, I guess.
Yeah. No, this is exactly this is exactly why if you're going
to say, "Hey, this guy couldn't master this audio this like incredibly
complicated audio engineer setup
within like a week or two or 3 weeks, four weeks, it might have
been like 2 months, right? 3 months
with other people tinkering with it all the time. if you'd given
him control over it. Right? This is one of those things where
your responsibilities have to meet your privileges or or like
uh yeah, your responsibilities have to meet your privileges.
If you want Lykan to be the person who's solely responsible for
the podcast working off of touching any of the you don't get
to go touch that [__] If you want the privilege of
touching the mics, touching the mixer, touching anything, then
do not say it's all Lykan's fault when breaks,
Your privileges and your responsibilities have to match up. If
you want to touch that [__] don't throw Lykan under
the bus. So, somebody says, "Pretty sure Lyan has a professional
role in tech support of some kind, but was laid off, so Destiny
hired him as a chef because he liked cooking." I don't know if
Lyan was laid off or not. I do think Destiny hired him as a chef
because he was a cook. He was a good cook and Destiny needed
somebody. And Destiny was saying before any of that happened,
I think Destiny was saying like, "I would pay somebody, but professional
chefs seem really expensive." And like it was like, "Hey, you
know, I I'd do this for a while. I think I want to try cooking."
The funny thing is is
I think for for
how up is it that it's a twoerson podcast. Okay.
Cherry and I set up a like a a sim like a somewhat similar studio
at my place.
And as much as listen, as much as um it might be annoying to
have the mics come through the same feed, there aren't really
audio issues, right? Unless we're not used to the directional
mics and I talk away from it, right? But there aren't really
audio issues.
It turns out if you just like get the setup that meets your that
is like actually appropriate for your standards, right? A two,
three, four mic setup, they're really simple mixers you can get.
Why didn't they just do that? I don't know. They they went for
this like astronaut setup that makes no sense.
Goofy. Okay, let's keep looking. This seems like an example of
Dan and Destiny's avoidant personalities in the most toxin and
toxic and maladaptive way. Yes.
Like and wanting 30% is hilariously insane, though. I don't know
if that actually makes sense. Oh, hold on. I forgot though. It
is very funny. Okay, just as one last piece of totally disingenuous,
skinwalking,
antisocial, disgusting behavior. Uh, don't forget Dan pressing
Hassan on this like exact issue. Okay, here. Hold on. Let me
let me take a look at this.
So, Redact. Dev is majority owned by its employees flat out.
Not a meme or a joke. More than 50%. They get market salaries
as well. Because of this, most of them are now millionaires.
I don't know if I believe any of that. I think he's probably
just lying there. But even if it's true, look at the next tweet.
Day six of waiting for Hassan the Han to let us know what percentage
of his enterprise worth tens of millions a year he shares with
his mods, editors, attorneys, and merch makers. Your team is
begging for rent money. Why? My team are millionaires. Why not
give them a cut and make them rich? Uh, okay.
I I guess I guess so. And I know exactly how Dan would respond
to this. He go, "Yeah, but that's me telling like Hassan to live
his values, and I'm like a capitalist. I'm like a ruthless capitalist."
Okay. What's the point about your employees? Why? This is just
an example of Dan never ever being serious, never like actually
having values. He just says whatever he needs to in the moment
to try to make whatever point he's making. He is like a goldfish
in terms of remembering what he said in the past, right? And
he was doing this for a while. Day seven of waiting for Hassan
Hunt to let us know what percentage of his and this is like June
of this year or something, right? So, how the do you how do the
do you think if I don't know if Lincoln ever saw this stuff?
But if he did, how do you think he feels watching that watching
you be a total hypocrite trying to call his out when you were
a complete piece of is bizarre. It's just it's ludicrous and
bizarre behavior. And by the way, at any point Dan could join
and try to defend himself, but he won't.
He won't ever. And that's fine.
We can see. We all see Dan just scams him. Oh, sure. You're talking
about anything else Dan. Dan basically just takes let Ly and
join and respond. Uh I messaged him. He hasn't messaged me back.
So I don't know if he wants to say anything. I'm speaking entirely
on I know. So I don't know. I'm I'm like making inferences and
I'm I'm I'm seeing things the way I saw it. When I when I first
heard about this, I was annoyed. I'm even more annoyed now that
they decided to take this public for no reason. Oh, and also
like Dan just gets free work from all of his employees all the
time, right? I don't know how much stardust ever made working
for him. I don't think it was a lot. If you read his articles
he filed with the state, I bet it's one of those setups where
he can force them to sell whenever he fires them. Aka, it's really
just their money that he gets to hold on to and use his leverage
like an interest free loan. Oh, maybe. I don't know. Dan doesn't
join a stream where the where the majority of people don't like
him. Uh, okay.
Well, that's uh becoming most streams pretty quickly, so we'll
see. What do you have Stardust doing? I think Stardust was editing
and making memes for him or some
uh this is not true.
This is just not true. Okay, with all that, I think I think that's
it for the Dan stuff.
I I thought it was super bizarre for him to do this. I We could
read a couple more comments. Lykan living up to his socialist
roots. I don't know why you think Lykan's a socialist.
Maybe unpopular opinion, but I think it's kind of crazy that
Kyle and Dan were 50/50 owners of their podcasts. Not only was
Destiny pretty much solely responsible for an audience showing
up, he did also a lot of the setup and talk. Yeah, this is actually
true. There's no reason Dan or Kyla should have been 50-50 owners
in those podcasts. Yeah, they they provided like 5% of the upfront
cost or work. Yes, they're totally like they're total parasites.
The only job they had was trying to get Destiny not to be a lazy,
right? That was their entire job. They just wrangled Destiny
to get him to sit down for an hour at a set time. That was the
job. They got 50% of the podcast for that. Kylo was an owner
of Bridges, right? Not the podcast. Kylo was an owner in Bridges
and owned the studio with him or something. Dan's other job was
banning Chatters who said they don't like Dan. Actually, NYSE
took questions from the Reddit and make a fabulous original set
design. Okay, this isn't even an unpopular opinion. This is probably
just true, right? Destiny Destiny did all of the capital spending.
He did he did like literally everything for this. That Rance
thing Rance thing was a canary in the coal mine in a lot of ways.
Are you talking about Ranton
or Rance? Cuz I feel like Rance is a name I know, but I don't
know where from. I watch any Dan anything else for Dan. Destiny
never wanted to be there. Uh, no that's not true. Green pepper.
That's not true. I guarantee you unless Green Pepper unless you
go watch a bunch of anything else now. Maybe you do. People say
that and I understand they like the Destiny Dan dynamic. It was
not that you just like Dan in a vacuum or I assume Dan would
get like, you know, a couple thousand concurrent when he streamed.
Destiny was straight checked out in a ton of episodes. I'm sure.
I'm sure he was. Yeah. I don't I don't know what I'm listening
to here. Apparently, these two middle-aged long-term business
owners would rather cook up a literal Jimmy McIll type scheme
to gaslight one of their oldest friends rather than just sit
him down with a tough conversation about his work performance.
Like, I get having that conversation with a friend is hard, but
what Dan is describing is so gleeully here sounds low-key sociopathic.
It's so offputting that even DGers are seeing through it and
being like, "Dude, isn't this like really weird and antisocial?
Isn't this like actually [__] terrifying that these
people are like act just total scumbags?
Yeah, it is.
It's It's crazy. Yeah. Yeah, they are. It's It's just very bizarre.
It's It's very very bizarre.
Bottom line, everyone is afraid of conflict. Everyone is a afraid
of conflict, but you have to if you're the person who controls
the money, you have to be thinking about the the people who don't,
right?
Like when it's a when it's friend situations, you could say never
hire a friend, which is a valid thing to say. just never hire
your friend to do work with you and and you avoid these situations.
But once you've done it, then you have to deal with that fact,
the fact that you've you've done it in the first place, right?
I'm completely out of my depth here, but what was making the
audio/vide video so inconsistent to the point that guests are
waiting hours plus to start a show, especially for instudio setups,
it seems like all the kinks would be worked out in testing prior
to the podcast launch. Yes, but people would tweak things all
the time. People would keep tweaking. They just keep tweaking.
The real question here is why did the audio continue to have
consistent hiccups after like left? Why did they continue to
have issues with the tech setup after like left? That's the real
question you should be asking, right? What happened there that
you guys continue to with things and you continue to have things
blow up after he leaves? This makes sense why Destiny's get so
anti- getting someone to help him. I've seen this happen one
million different times. You hire a friend or family member and
they just suck. That's why again I am putting in my application.
Yeah, it turns out that uh this applies to somebody else around
him as well, but it's fine. Why not hire a real audio engineer?
I I don't know why you wouldn't try to do a setup that, you know,
could match the capacity of somebody who is trying to learn on
the job. This I I can't believe the the like obsession of these
people with like trying to take all responsibility away from
Destiny. Destiny just doesn't know how to hire people. He doesn't
know how to pick people. He should get a life coach to pick his
friends and co-workers for him. Okay, it's goofy. Okay, I'm pretty
much got to be close to done. 30% with zero job experience is
so funny. Again, to me, and I don't know for sure. I heard significantly
lower than that. And not only that, you have to think about what
Lykan could be doing otherwise, right? But Lyan left, he went
to do a different job. He probably was thinking of his long-term
earning potential, his career, how his life was going to go.
I think at somewhere around this point, he had started dating
Aaron. It seemed like he got pretty serious about it pretty quickly,
right? If he wants to build a life with Aaron, then why the is
he going to sit there earning whatever he makes on this show
instead of trying to go out and and like
get financially stable? And it turns out, by the way, him leaving
was 100%. Yeah. Listen, Aaron's little boooo liu budget is not
low. All right? Aaron's Lubu budget is crazy. And if Lyan's going
to support that long term, he's got to think of a better plan.
All right? He's going to need he's going to need something substantial.
All right?
That's true.
[laughter] I remember when Ratton had to wait five hours before
they went live or something. That was post like and anything
else. [laughter]
That's what I'm saying. Like there's an obvious It's obvious
he wasn't the problem. It's obvious.
Or at least he wasn't the whole problem. He wasn't even close
to the whole problem. The aftermath to that was great. Both Dan
and Destiny knew they [__] up, but they also wanted
to still play up the character of never doing anything wrong
to save face. It was so fun watching them squirm every time the
topic was brought up.
Wasn't that Kyla? Oh, he also I believe he also had to wait for
Kyla. No, dude. People just hate on Lykan. Classic. He showed
the same level of preparation and confidence whenever he hopped
on stream to discuss Israel Palestine.
Uh I don't think it's true. He was wrong. It's not like he was
unprepared or like I just People are like, "Oh, he's totally
unprepared."
No, he was just He might have been wrong. That's the best you
could do. He clearly like read these books. He clearly went and
like was citing sources. He was clearly like trying to do something
and you're like attacking the book he's going through. What did
you expect him to go through and like triple link through to
all of Finkelestein sources? Finkelestein's sources and like
check. Dude, nobody's doing that. That's not being unprepared.
That's a level of preparedness that you'd only do if you were
professionally doing these things. Like if you took 6 months
to to 12 months to study Israel Palestine so you could try to
debate it professionally.
Like you're comparison you're comparing Destiny's level of preparation
where he's getting hundreds of thousands of dollars a month.
Yeah. Even still during the Israel Palestine thing probably something
like a hundred thousand to multiple hundreds of thousands of
dollars a month to go through this stuff, right? And be like
a professional authority. Try to seem like a professional authority
on the topic. And you're like, "Oh, well, you didn't meet Destiny's
level." Who would? There's literally nobody who would who would
go through all of that work. There's like PhD scholars and
I don't know like nobody else. Yeah, sure. Exactly, Rhox. But
I'm saying I'm like Desty spent a ton of time doing that. That's
not the base level of preparation for having internet debates.
Anyway, between this and Lykan's recent appearance on Hutch's
stream, I'm reminded how insufferable he was. And I'm glad he
doesn't come on the streams anymore. Okay.
And at the end, he would still say, "Well, I don't know if Lykan
is anti-Semitic." Dude, the whole like is anti-semitic thing
is just so goofy.
And I'll say again and again and again like Lyan's basic point
was the previous operations Israel has done don't seem to like
match their stated intentions. Uh they seem to like actually
go pretty hard. They seem to not really consider these people
humans. I'm very scared about how this will go. I'm very scared
about like how much overreach will be allowed here. And then
Israel cleared out the entire strip and like 100,000 people or
whatever 70,000 100,000 somewhere in there. Right?
So Ly is just totally correct. Lyen actually was totally correct.
He didn't argue it well but his fundamental premise was correct
at the end of the
Israel massively overreached. Israel massively with the Gazin
the Gazin people right the Palestinians. Not the VOD but I think
the entirety of the talk is in this video as Lykan and Hutch.
To me, it's kind of a bad situation. >> Was on Hutch a
couple days ago. Oh, this is the Grand Platner thing. Okay,
sure. Like and thought maybe you don't get rid of Grand Graham
Platner because of the tattoo. I have like some thoughts like
I understand why people wouldn't want to vote for Platiner. I
The issue for me is the tattoo is indicative of like a thought
process of a way of living where I'm almost positive he'll have
worse things. And that's further backed up by the fact that he's
lost two campaign managers in like 2 weeks.
So, I just assume there's way more stuff. There's like a there's
like a way of living or a thought process there for Graham Platner
that seems to me to indicate that this isn't the only thing he's
going to have come out and and there are going to be major problems.
Is kick lagging? Is it only me? Yeah. Somebody tell two legs
Z can save him. Oh, sorry. On the Platiner front, let me pull
the Z to the hill tweet cuz it was uh it was [__]
crazy.
Let me let me pull this. We we should watch this as well now
that we have Platiner get brought up. messages for >> just
wait. You guys have no idea how like everything starts to make
sense when I watch this
this Yeah, we watch this off stream. Everything starts to make
sense when I watch this. Internet, please get this message to
Graham for
>> Okay. This message is for Graham Platner, the guy that's
an oyster farmer that's running against Susan Collins in Maine.
If you are not >> He's not running against Susan Collins
yet, just to be clear. He is running against Janet Mills, I believe.
Um, some incredibly ancient 77year-old woman.
So, he's running in the Dem primary first. >> Graham, I
need you please to get him this video. Tag his campaign. Send
it to him in DM. I don't care what it is, but don't keep scrolling.
Just make sure that he sees this. Okay, before I tell you guys
what the message is to Graham that I need you to get to him,
I need you to understand what happened. Okay, really quick. So,
about a week ago, we found out about the controversial tattoo.
Okay, who gives a [__] Um, also the Reddit messages.
Also, who gives a [__] If this is like the craziest
in this guy's background, then he's probably like one of the
better candidates I've ever worked with. And the the old lady's
the current governor of Maine or a former governor of Maine,
Rhinox. I didn't even know that. >> Also, he's raised like
almost $4 million against Susan Collins, who is goddamn awful.
And I'm pretty sure she would be like the oldest person ever
to be sworn into that seat. Okay. Um, he sent out a bunch of
NDAs because obviously his team had like the second meeting,
right? We all know about the second meeting and they probably
tried to coup or whatever and so he offered his political director
15 grand and she turned it down which I think is absolutely insane.
But that's not even the craziest part of this
>> Isn't it way more likely that he just has like more
scandals coming out that he doesn't want people to know about
and the people who are on the campaign don't think it's worth
like their like their political futures to to continue working?
Is that just infinitely more likely here
that there's just more to come? Hey, hey, I hired a new campaign
manager.
They signed on. They signed an NDA and then they quit and were
like, "Hey, I just found out I'm having a baby. I don't want
to do this."
Either that baby's so far away it won't matter. Or that baby's
coming. You knew that baby was coming when you accepted the job.
Which one is it? I tend to think it's I tend to think it's the
first one or sorry the second one where you knew the baby was
coming and you you signed up this job and now you're using it
as a like a pretext for leaving.
Okay. So then we have a campaign reshuffle and then Graham hires
a new campaign manager. This is about a week ago and now 2 days
ago this guy quits. Why does his new campaign manager quit? Because
he says it's because now they found out he has a baby on the
way. No. Um, really we all know that he just was probably chicken
and couldn't handle any type of controversy. Now that you guys
have the background, this is the part that I need Graham to see.
So, I have been working campaigns for over a decade. I run a
political organization of a team of all women that are incredibly
fierce and we are not afraid of controversy at all. Okay? I will
get >> Listen Listen, we we run people with all kinds of
crazy scandals. Okay? We work with people who are who are total
degenerates who have like the worst scandals you could think
of. Graham. All right. You just a tattoo. Oh, that's lightweight.
We just had a call one of the friends of our headliner the hard
R at my event last week. Not tattoos light work, baby. Let's
go light your name free of charge and I will help you run this
campaign. I'm 25 weeks pregnant. I don't care that I have a kid
on the way. I will make sure that your campaign.
>> Shouldn't you care about that? Shouldn't this be like
a potentially stressful thing? Shouldn't you be like maybe concerned
about Shouldn't that be a thing that's in the back of your head?
A little bit.
Maybe
perhaps.
I have a baby on the way. I'm 22 weeks pregnant. I have a baby
on the way. I don't give a Okay, I'll I'll do a keg stand right
now. Try and stop me. >> Is well taken care of. And again,
I will do this completely free of charge. So if you want to take
me >> I literally I don't even need money. my baby my life.
I don't even need money to support the guy to >> I will
help you run this campaign. I'm 25 weeks pregnant. I don't care
that I have a kid on the way. I will make sure that your campaign
is well taken care of. And again, I will do this completely free
of charge. So, if you want to take me up on this offer, please
send me an email. I'm going to put it in the description below.
Give me a call and we will try to make this happen. And >> so
this to me throws up like a thousand different red flags for
Zo for Zoe's bonafides, right? I don't know that anybody serious
in the political space has ever interacted with her. I I suddenly
am like, "Oh, you're like a total opportunist, like a total
who has no morals and is just going to do what?" You're like
a George Santos type of person. That's that's like what I'm seeing
when I see this message go out. I'm like, "Oh, oh, you're like
you're kind of like a George Santos but for political campaigns."
Exhibitionist as in yes, she wants to be publicly embarrassed.
She's she just wants the limelight. She wants to put herself
on exhibition. Not nec.
But just in a general way. Is this her trying to jump ship? No,
it's not. It's definitely not.
I just I have no idea where this where this comes from. >> And
again, thank you internet for getting this into his hands.
Yeah. I don't know. I love that Graham Platner is like, "Wait,
you think with all this scandal like I'm a good bet? You you're
going to do this for free?" Yeah. I that this is like
this energy. There's no way you would ever hire this person.
Right. Even Even if you're Graham Platiner, I feel like there's
no chance you would hire this person. You're like, "Oh, you're
like way too desperate for this." Yeah. No, thank you. You're
there's something weird going on here and I don't want any part
of it. Absolutely deranged stuff. Very goofy.
Uh might check this out in a little bit. the Grand Platiner stuff.
Could check this out. Might be interesting. Could be interesting.
But for now, I think I might cut over to the cutie Cinderella
stuff.
let's check it out. Excuse me.
What is this? Hold on. Quick meme.
>> My younger cousin was watching this on his iPad. Full
volume, full brightness.
Okay. What the [__]
>> Dude, what the
uh AI was a mistake.
Did Zezy send you this? I don't know if Zezy sent it. Cherry
sent me this, but I don't know where she got it. Jesus. I don't
I think the only reaction to this is uh every day we stray further
from God's light. It's just that the world is not going in a
good direction.
I Okay, Cherry says she didn't send me
All right, I just I just found this myself. Okay, this came up
on my for you page today, guys.
Yeah, naturally just served to me automatically. All right,
let's try to hit the highlights on the cutie Cinderella stuff,
I think.
Oh,
Oh, maybe I want to go to the miz stuff
>> Yeah, there's just miz updates from the last time, like
based on the last time we covered it. There's just more miz updates
here. I'm going to check this out. I had this in the docket.
I don't think it's like connected to anything. I was going to
hit play on this. I said really quickly cuz I just drank like
three different things of liquid. So, I'll be right back. I said
like 2 liters of liquid as I started stream. I'm going to hit
play. Uh, Assad thinks Asmin Gold wouldn't be able to handle
the same level of scrutiny he gets. If Asmin Gold had the same
level of scrutiny from dedicated smear campaigners that I have
or even a fraction, he would be ritualistically humiliated on
the timeline. Incapable shame.
Okay, I don't know what that last part means. Also, I don't think
Asminold has the same like shame capacity that Hassan does. Asmin
Gold geily tells you about the rat, the dead rat that he uses
an alarm clock as it would bake in the st in the sun. Where is
the shame going to come from?
He's not ashamed of that. What would he be ashamed of? He doesn't
leave his house. I think Asminold could be ashamed of like bad
actions he done, but he doesn't interact with other humans. He
can't have scandals because he doesn't interact with other humans
at all. Right. So, the thing is like I do think he would be ashamed
if he had scandals like Tee does, but he isn't going to have
those cuz he doesn't talk to other people. He's like immune to
them. Anyway, I'll be right back. this to be repulsive.
And I do think that the average person, like
I'll keep it a buck 50. If Asmin Gold had the same level of
from the same dedicated
smear campaigners that I have or even a fraction of the attention,
I think he would be
he would be ritualistically humiliated on the timeline. Now,
obviously, he is incapable of feeling shame. That's why he constantly
promotes the fact that he doesn't shower or even uh even hypes
up and and uh uh embellishes
uh how little he cares about drinking water, for example. Like,
he's exaggerating. like he knows that that's like a marketable
position for a lot of the people that also exhibit his
uh lifestyle that spend every waking moment
Okay.
He likes it. He likes when people go crazy over this stuff when
he says like, "Oh, I'm not showering because it's like up my
evolution or whatever." >> Okay. Hassan is already hitting
on the fact that Asminold does not experience shame like the
normal person. So, okay.
>> The reality of the matter is he's been able to carve
out a place for himself without actually getting a lot of scrutiny
from the broader public. Most people don't know who the he is,
but people online who spend every waking moment online
do know who he is. You're better than doing an ad homonym, man.
Brother, an ad hom.
>> Oh, hello. We ban Ruben donated $3. Wait, so as Mongolds
got that same thing that that one Connie had on community can't
feel shame.
>> I actually don't even know what you're talking about.
The one car. Oh yeah. Yeah, he's got that. Yeah, he kind of looks
like that Carne a little bit too. Yeah, I do know what you're
talking about. Never mind. Yeah, it is kind of like that. Okay,
hold on. I'm looking for Apparently Asminold responds to this
>> Name calling him. Nothing I said about Asmin Gold so
far
is is something that he hasn't divulged himself. The reason why
you think this is actually like name calling him is because you
also are kind of embarrassed by the fact that your favorite content
creator or someone that you frequently watch has horrible hygiene
practices that he unironically presents and promotes as a positive.
>> Oh, I can't find the Asmold response to any of this.
I'm looking for it. I look for it on O. I can't I cannot see
it.
I don't see the asmin response at all. Oh, hold on. Maybe maybe
this is it. I'm not sure. This be the Asmin response. >> Other
communities
then their fan bases will be much more charitable
to my world view. And God forbid. >> He's right. He's absolutely
right. But this has been the operating principle that people
like him have used in order to suppress their opposition for
the last 10 years. The problem is that now that it's happening
to him, he views it as an issue. But when it was happening to
other people, it's about keeping the community safe. But when
it's happening to you, it's oppression. >> Maybe even change
their perspective.
>> But that's it.
>> Bro, you my favorite podcast to protect people from
your blast radius. Well, I mean, yeah. I I I don't want I don't
let anybody h I don't let
Wait, that's not uh Fear End, is it? Did they cancel Fear End?
What was his favorite podcast? Anybody have to tank any of my
Like You can ask any friend of mine ever? Like, have they have
I ever asked for any support on any issue ever for anything?
And the answer is never. Never. Not even >> Hud's problem
is unrelated to you. Um, yeah. I mean, I'm I'm not very familiar
with what happened. I'm just talking about my own
principles that I oftentimes repeat. >> Yeah. You're you're
getting isolated because people think that the viewpoints are
problematic. It's actually pretty simple. Like there's not really
a whole lot to it with this is pretty
that's Asmin Gold knows this isn't true, right? Asminold knows
that for 99% of influencers, especially the LA kind, the appearance
of Scandal is the same as Scandal. That they're never really
looking into these things, that they don't process the information.
They're just like, "Oh, that's like kind of radioactive. I'm
not going to go near that for a little bit." That like actually
doesn't matter. Now, Hassan's immune to that on some level, like
he's been immune to it historically, but to go, "Oh, yeah. People
actually absorb all the information. They look at every perspective
and they come to like a reasonable logical conclusion." Asol
doesn't believe that even remotely, but he's suggesting so here.
>> It's pretty [__] obvious, right? I mean,
like people like it's the same as like me like I mean Hassan
and I have extreme viewpoints on things. We do. We have extreme
viewpoints and a lot of people don't want to involve a brand
that they've built up on the internet with extreme viewpoints.
That's it. It It's literally that simple. Because like if you
bring somebody like me or somebody like Assan on the on your
platform, you are even if you don't take a side, there's enough
people on the internet that are radicalized enough to think that
you are. And that's the reason why uh you know he doesn't get
invited to stuff. That's the reason why I don't get invited to
stuff. It's because we say crazy and that's the cost. I don't
And again, it's not like I'm going to stop saying it, but that's
just what's going to happen.
So now everyone hates him because he abused his dog. Well, I
mean, you remember the Trash Taste thing happened before and
like Trash Taste even came out and like roached out on Hassan
too, even though he's personal friends with a number of them.
And the reason why is because at the end of the day, it's a business.
And I've said I say this all the time, it's a business
first. And but he understands that businesses don't make these
decisions based on what's right. Right.
Did OTK ditch Rich Campbell because it was the right thing to
do or did they do it to cover their assment gold?
I'm sorry that it's He keeps saying it's like proof that Hassan
is wrong, right? He's like he's like making this assertion, but
I think he knows full well that it doesn't necessarily say that
Hassan's wrong. It just says that Hassan is like catching flack
for this,
which by the way, I would even agree Hassan could be wrong. Like
if he shocked his dog, he said in the past he would never do
that. That would be wrong probably, right? Like I could admit
that's wrong or say that's wrong, but it doesn't have to do with
the reality of the situation. It just has to do with the optics
>> and and friendship second. >> Also, I don't know
why I pulled this clip. I I don't need this clip.
I was just looking for the response, but we we don't have it
to the previous Hassan clip. I will watch one more Hassan clip
from that same stream. >> The terrorist >> real quick.
He's also
apparently Hassan called out Asminold for dodging free and open
debate.
>> I saw a clip yesterday where he said you >> bro
sweatpants freedom. I don't know about you, I find it insane
that people can't go, "Oh, haha, Hassan abused his dog." And
also JD Vance is totally insane for trying to make this claim
when Christy Gnome's the head of DHS. Like you're saying that
people who hurt animals are basically Jeffrey Dmer. Well, Christy
Gnome's in charge of the DHS. Why the [__] did you
nominate Jeffrey Dmer but the female version to be in charge
of DHS?
Anybody who can't make both of those statements at the same time
is is like totally audience captured or something. You won't
talk to him. You've reached out though. So he's just straight
up not telling the truth or lying by a mission. No, he is just
straight up telling his audience an alternative version of events.
There has never been a moment where I have refused to talk to
Asmin Gold. Okay. anytime, any place. So, one must ask the question
why he routinely finds different reasons as to why he won't talk.
And when you're questioning that, you should also question why.
>> Uh-oh. Is Hassan Hassan's calling him a right now? Right.
Am I Am I hearing this correctly? That Assan is saying Asminold
is a gigantic f I do find there's two things that are funny here.
One one thing that makes this really funny is that Hassan does
the same thing all the time. He refused to debate people who
criticize him, right?
Which is fair, but also like he's just leaning into it. And Asmin
Gold's also picked me. [laughter]
It's like both of them. The pot calling the kettle black right
now. Right.
That's like obviously what it is. Let me see if I can find I'm
going to take a quick look at Asmin Gold's VOD. See if I can
find it. Scanning. Scanning. Scanning. Scanning. It would have
been yesterday that he responded to it, right? Oh, wait. This
is from today. It's probably yesterday where he responds to it.
Let me pull this up. I'm gonna see if we can find Asmin Gold's
response to this specific section of his own. It would be later,
right? Doing some quick zooies through the the scan
Looking looking, look. Ah, here it is. Here it is. Just do it.
>> Asmin thinks Hassan or sorry, Hassan thinks Asmin wouldn't
be Here we go. Here it is.
>> Sakar, who cares? Oh no, there's another one. Of course
there is. Of course. >> I do find a lot of this to be repulsive
and I do think that the average person like
I'll keep it a buck 50. If Asmin Gold had the same level of scrutiny
>> from the same dedicated
smear campaigners that I have or even a fraction I mean then
you know the world would be a little bit correct cuz I know the
people smear campaigning Hassan and why they're not going after
Asmin Gold is totally beyond mention >> of the attention.
I think he would be
he would be ritualistically humiliated on the timeline. Now,
obviously, he is
>> this this already
>> I will also say though that there's another key thing
here that Hassan doesn't understand, he's probably incapable
of understanding. And that's that despite Asmin Gold having that
one genocide statement. Asminold is like 100 times more careful
than Hassan is in the things he says, and he's 100 times more
calculated in the things he does to rage bait. Hassan doesn't
understand this. San just fires from the hip all the time. Asmin
Gold is actually like very calculated in the ways that he is
like offensive and transgressive.
Yes, Frain he is. It makes it very difficult to attack him. Asmin
just doesn't get clipped. Asmin gets clipped all the time. What
are you saying? Asmin always gets clipped. What are you talking
about? He is clipped constantly.
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you that he is far. His video YouTube video was banworthy.
Which one? I don't know which one. Oh, the the doxing one. Yeah,
the doxing one was unhinged. But I said during the doxing one,
Vraane, I said that this is way outside the norm for Asminold.
He's normally way more controlled than this. He's normally way
more calculated than this. Yes, he was totally insane after the
Charlie Kirk thing, but he he has like those moments. I'm saying
most of the time he is far more controlled, far more calculated
than Hassan in what he says and how he's transgressive.
Even with the clip, even with the clip everybody's freaking out
about where he goes, he's right. He's right. Even when he does
that, it's difficult to criticize him because it's all like kind
of abstract. It's not like 100% clear what he means, right? He
he can just fall back to like, "Yeah, if people break the laws,
I think they should be arrested." Why do you disagree with that?
And then what are you saying? What are you soying out about at
that point?
You look you look like a totally soy liberal re at that point,
right? This happens all the time.
>> Is incapable of feeling shame. That's why he constantly
promotes the fact that he doesn't shower or even >> of
course. Why would I feel shame? Because I Why would I be ashamed
of doing what I want to do? Yeah. Why? Why? Why would I? >> Shame
is basically just a thing you feel about doing wrong actions
or actions that are socially like negatively stereotyped. Not
showering is negatively socially stereotyped. Like stinky stinky
people get made fun of.
As Gold's like, "Why would I be ashamed to be stinky? Why why
do I have to not stink?" It's like, uh, you don't. You just,
you know, it's totally antisocial weirdo behavior. It's indicative
of like major problems. If you do things that like nobody else
in society does,
that's fine if you're willing to admit that you're like in a
bad place, right? Like if Asen Gold was like, "Guys, I'm really
depressed and I just can't get in the shower." It's like, okay,
that's understandable, right? I understand that from like a certain
point of view. But he doesn't do that. He goes, "It's actually
awesome that I don't shower. It's actually so cool. Like, I'm
based for having like uh actual mental problems." And that's
just like that's just the other side of the coin of the person
who puts, you know, neurode divergent. Uh I have like all these
mental issues in their bio and then like uses them as as Pokemon
cards, as like trading cards, right? He's just that person. He
just doesn't seem that way because he also is like on a different
side of Gamer Cape basically.
But it's the exact same behavior when he when he describes his
super antisocial behaviors is like positive or not things to
be ashamed of. He is engaging in basically like weaponizing autism,
right? Oh, you please be sensitive. I'm on he's just doing the
same.
It's it's the exact same thing. It's just not his side of the
the aisle doesn't really call that out. It's auto satire. I think
the difference is he doesn't genuinely think it's truly
Uh I'm telling you he understands it's bad. He presents it as
not shame worthy, right? It's like it's a it's like a joke, but
it's also he legitimately there's no way you live in that house
for that long without legitimate mental illness, right? That
house was insane. His house with like the the newspaper stacked
to the ceiling and like that's
That's obviously like out of this world bad because he'd sit
there and he'd go, "No, I don't have to clean that up." No, that's
totally normal. That's fine. Why would I have to clean that up?
It's like again, he's not he's not saying like, "I have a problem,
right? If he could acknowledge the problem and work on it, that's
way different." But he doesn't. He glorifies it.
I I mean, I I I'm not accountable to anybody. I don't have to
do what anybody wants me to do. I can do whatever I
So why would I ever feel shame for
If I want to do something, I just do it. Even hypes up and and
uh uh embellishes
uh how little he cares about drinking water, for example. Like
he's exaggerating. Like he knows that that's like a marketable
position for a lot of the people that it's called a joke.
I I I I get I get that you're strung up and you're wound up over
this. I get that you're upset, but we just joking around, man.
Like, it's not it's not that serious. >> Also, exhibit
his
uh lifestyle that spend every waking moment online.
Okay.
He likes it. He likes when people go crazy. >> You just
got trolled,
bro. I can't be trolled. There's just there's literally like
if you could timelapse Asmin Gold's like in his room, you see
stuff build up. You see the mountains of trash build up in the
background. You can't say he's trolling when I can see the piles
of trash. Okay. You over this stuff when he says like, "Oh, I'm
not showering because it's like [__] up my evolution
or whatever." Of course I do. Cuz it's funny. Yeah, it's funny.
I I don't need to like duh.
Of course. It's like it's funny watching people get mad. >> The
irony posting defense.
He used to have he used to be better than that than just the
the Schroingers claim.
>> Like it's funny. I was only pretending to be guys
>> watching the reactions. I think it's hilarious. And
and if people get offended by it or annoyed or upset about it,
that's the risk that you take. And you know that that's their
prerogative. If they want to get upset about something like that,
it's up to them. So, I don't know what to say.
>> The reality of the matter is >> he's been able
to carve out a place for himself without actually getting a lot
of scrutiny from the broader public. Most people don't know who
>> who the he is. That's just not true. I That's such a
weird signal. That's such a weird thing for Hassan to say. He's
bigger than you and literally everybody knows who you are. The
vice president literally just referred to you. Do you think the
vice president doesn't know who Asminold is?
I guarantee you JD Vance is very aware of who both Asminold and
Hassan [__] are.
>> But people online who spend every waking moment online
do know who he is. You're better than doing an ad hominemum,
man. Brother [laughter] and
God. Oh no.
>> This is okay. I will say on one level it's very funny
when Hassan does this, right? It's very funny that Hassan does
this. It kind of like it's like, oh, the people are pushing back
against him. What I don't understand is how nobody nobody gets
that this is like his brand that he's like made a career. He
has made millions and millions and millions of dollars from being
the one guy from being sorry from being the guy who is one guide.
Like that is that is what his brand is. This is like this is
the actual when he laughs and goes, "Oh, look what look at what
an idiot this guy is." is the same as the song calling you out
as gold for having all the trash. Right. It's like the It's like
the opposite. You're just mirroring the same thing. It's like
you're you're trying to laugh as if this is like bad for him
when this is his brand. He finds people who disagree with him
and he yells at >> No, no.
This ad homonym
would imply
I can't tell you how funny it is, how like deeply hilarious it
is for all of these people to always go, how many times you go,
even Hassan's own audience disagrees with them. How is that true?
Every single day for years and years on end and he only gains
viewers. Oh, even Hassan's audience disagrees with him. Oh, I
don't know. Are they showing up?
It seems like he gets a lot of support. You know what I'm saying?
Oh, Hassan's audience is finally turning on him. How many times
have I seen Hassan's audience is turning on him? Like a thousand.
>> That I'm name calling him. Nothing I said about >> just
attacking a person's character. I mean like that's I don't think
ad hominemum has to be a name calling. I could be wrong though.
I don't I don't remember
so far
is is something that he hasn't divulged himself. The reason why
you think this is actually like name calling him is because you
also are kind of embarrassed by the fact that your favorite content
creator or someone that you frequently watch has horrible hygiene
practices that he unironically presents and promotes as a positive.
I never do that. Oh god. Okay. So, um, yes. Oh, wow. I I don't
even know what to say. I really don't even know what to say.
And ad homonym is direct is a of an argument or reaction is directed
against a person rather than a position they're maintaining.
Yeah, that's what I thought, right? I mean, it's been a long
time. So, I mean,
actually taught me to shower less. Oh, I did. And I I don't know
what to say. Don't be like me. Yeah, bro. I've said I treat,
you know, you should treat your body like a temple. I treat mine
like a zoo. Yeah. It's it's pretty common, right? And uh I I
I don't know what to say about it. I mean, it it's just insane
to me to see this. And the the my favorite part about watching
this every time is that he gets goated by his chat into getting
more mad about something.
Um I understand this to some extent, Kendrick Lam. I understand
this in that Asold's uh very good at emoting. Asold's like a
very entertaining streamer. If you like him and disagree his
political points but still like watching him like do his thing
and be funny, I'm okay with that. Right.
I think I think if you could acknowledge his political positions
often are harmful and you just enjoy the content anyway, I'm
okay with that. >> That I didn't say.
Did you hear that Asmin said that you were a terrorist and you
should get deported? Oh, YOU KNOW WHAT? I TELL YOU SO. >> He's
got a lot of different kinds of bugs, a lot of different species
of bugs and molds in there. Pants freedom said the opposite.
>> Yeah. I don't know what to say. Right. We have insiders.
Yeah. So, just gassing them up. I mean, I I it it's funny to
watch it happen. It really is. But, um
kind of embarrassing, too. I mean, I don't know what else to
say. [snorts] And uh yeah,
I electrocute you. Yes. And and I understand like people like
Hassan I think that the the thing is that Hassan cares a lot
about what people think about him. And I do too to an extent,
right? But I think that I care more that people I guess like
know about me than people like me. And so um you know whereas
he I think cares a lot about how people see him whereas I just
care that people see me. And I think that over time people will
learn to like me. And so I think that really what happens is
that, you know, he sees like the way that I do things and and
everything and, you know, like I'm I'm very like open about it.
And I don't know why, but he just doesn't like it because that's
not what he does. And what he does is he's very focused on presenting
himself as a very particular type of person, being seen as this
type of an individual. That's why the dog thing bothered him
so much. Like if it was me, I'd be like, "Yeah, I shot that dog.
I shocked that." That's what he gets. That's what he gets. That's
what he's supposed to send here. Yeah. Get back in your place,
[__]
And that would be it. Right. But the thing is that
I think that he's, and this is the problem, is that his
fixation around being perceived in a certain way
always ends up being his uh being his his >> dude. Oh,
hold on.
Okay, hold on. Never mind. weakness.
>> And I think that, you know, really the dog collar thing
is a great example of >> And I think there's other examples
of that, too, but that's probably the best example that I can
use right off the right. Right off the right off the rip. And
so I started watching you. I thought u to confirm what I thought
I hated about you. Then I became a fan. Crazy, right? Yeah. No.
No. Welcome to the majority. Right. I mean, that's it. And so
invalid facade. Yeah. I mean, as for me, I mean, like I generally
like >> I I try to be as honest and direct with people
as I can be in terms of that's generally what I try. He's not
done watching, right? >> Like that's the way that it doesn't
make is the most humble people who care a lot about that's when
>> I actually don't care anymore about any perspective.
I think >> I do want this if he goes there. >> Shut
up. >> Yeah. I And nobody cares
philosophical. Jesus Christ. >> Is that
that's a nope. >> Oh, he skip he skipped the techone thing.
I can find any and and so that's generally the way that I look
at things. I mean obviously people can see it a little bit more
but overall that's kind of what I'm saying. What are you >> or
not >> want
you three times on train just like >> so you're saying
>> I just need to see if I
>> or that >> there's like another bit from that
bod that watches but it might be the next day or something. their
their opinion is so important >> there. I wanted to watch
this clip and just see the responses and but it's fine
>> cuz I don't think I don't think we caught this part
or maybe I just missed it and it was there but I don't think
we caught this part >> agree on many issues. >> Oh
this is sorry this is son going back and watching his own reaction.
>> You and you and Zach actually agree on many issues but
you will never know because it's more lucrative to y'all to talk
about and around each other instead of directly to each other.
I have not really talked about Asmin Gold despite the fact that
he's the large brother
Cap.
I
does he I I feel like he consistently says what a bunch of other
people say who are around him, which is why are lefties why are
people who are left of center attacking me instead of attacking
Asmin Gold, the biggest streamer on Twitch who has like these
insane takes. I do feel like he talks about Asmin Gold a >> political
content creator on this platform for the past couple of months.
In the process of me not talking about Asmin Gold, I'm willing
to bet that he has done at least one, if not
three videos a week about me.
>> I have also said,
by the way, this is unimaginably parasocial. You and Zach,
like you guys are besties, dude.
>> You said you and Zach would get times that I would talk
to him directly. >> I'm telling you, I know Zack, okay?
I know him personally. you guys would get along. You guys would
have a good good time together. >> Necessary if he wants
to do that on any number of different issues. I think for >> people
like totally misuse this term lcow. I think
you have to have like some reasonable argument that the person's
like descending, right? That they're on like a spiral to make
the lcal argument. And there are so many creators that there's
just like no evidence they're descending at all.
Uh did you see Dan talking about FCC trying to give Lyan a job
and making fun of how he screwed it up? Um, no. You could link
it if you want. I'm sure it's just more of him being psychopathic.
Just totally psychopathic for no reason. You could link it if
you want. I'd check it out. Probably.
normal position that he has. He has 10 repulsive ones that he
promotes with regular frequency. Come on. The bot. >> Sure.
But then like then every major content creator is a local, right,
Luawi? Like Asminold's a local, Hassan's a lowcal, desi's a local
cow, every OTK creator is a local.
It like kind of loses some specialized meaning. And maybe you
want to argue that that's
not as popular as he seems. I mean, he's still pretty popular
on YouTube, >> Hassan seems fake and Asmin seems genuine.
Just my read. I don't know if I agree with that. It's that might
be in some ways could possibly be true. Could possibly be in
that direction.
I don't I think Hassan seems like
I guess it depends on what I'm hearing about for him to seem
fake. He definitely seems like real sometimes.
Asmin Gold seems real sometimes. It would depend on like what
they're talking about in general. Yeah, I that's that's what
I was thinking. Evil Johnny
Yeah, like it like you basically
it's not even to their goals. It's like you basically consistently
self-destruct. You're like a Sideshow Bob walking into rakes.
You have to have like a reasonable argument for that. I don't
But I don't see that with either Hassan or Asmin Gold.
I do see that with like, you know, you you dox the person who
you were as a minor. That's that's like one of those things where
I'm like, yeah, you're you're meeting the criteria, but other
than that guy, I with these two, I don't really see it as much,
you know? Okay,
where are we going from there? I was going to watch one Miz clip.
I'm going to do the Miskip stuff before I do the cutie Cinderella
stuff. I think the miz stuff will be good.
Give me a second and we're going to go find it. Miz miz mizzy.
Oh yes. Hold on. There's a there's a new a clip. That's what
I was looking for. Where is it at? Where is it at? Hassan whole
response.
Wait. Hassan responded to all that.
Wait, what is the whole response? I'll I'll take a quick look.
We'll see if there's anything interesting there and then we're
moving on. We're going back to Miz. When I say he's a grifter,
I'm not saying that because uh I'm being charitable to him. When
I say he's a grifter, I'm saying that because it's the truth.
The pendulum were to swing
>> I mean, I Yeah, I'm going to agree with a lot of what
Hassan says here. Maybe I'll watch it off stream or something.
Or maybe we'll include it in some other segment here just a little
bit. I think it's probably not something I want to keep going
through today.
What was I looking for? I'm looking for this O tweet about this
new misk clip that's taking off on LSF. Where's it at? This one
right here.
What was this? A 2022 mis clip of Msk is sorry. Appearing to
mold at Emiru over finding molded cheese in the fridge is making
waves in
>> Watch. Watch for the rabbit to commit sapuku. Okay.
At this exact moment in time, we're looking for the the new theory
in the Discord is is that these rabbits actually die due to loud
noises. Misk punches a wall. Rabbit freaks out, runs into another
wall, and breaks his neck. Okay. Misk was actually the one the
rabbits, and he's trying to cover it up by blaming Emir.
>> You're in trouble. >> Why? What did I do? >> That
chubby found something. That's
>> Show chat.
>> Ew. What? >> That's yours. It's literally yours.
>> That's mine. I'm sorry. I didn't know it was in there.
>> Then why'd you buy it? Why don't you show chat? your
show and tell. >> Ew, bro. E [laughter] >> show chat.
>> No, I don't want to touch it.
>> You see it, Chad? It's fungus. >> I literally
can't I literally can't see >> I don't remember buying
that. Which means if I did buy a spin, >> this is not even
like >> I don't even know how. It looks like it's evaporated.
You see it? Can I see >> Play of the game.
>> This is not Why you saying ew me? This is hers.
She's been addicted to playing Overwatch and not paying attention
to her food. Should I keep holding it here? >> This has
to
>> This is unfortunately
This is where I see just the Misk character and it's like indistinguishable.
Like this could be bad. I'm not saying it's not bad for sure,
but it could just be like the Misk character who does this.
>> You want it? >> No. Stop.
>> You want it? Yes. Here.
>> Just throw it away. >> They said they want it.
Here, take it. I'm trying not to overread cuz like the thing
about Miz for a long time is he makes everybody feel awkward.
He like builds up these awkward moments, right? So I get why
this is
there were leaked DMs about this though. Wait, where are the
leaked DMs about this?
Hold on
cuz I could see this being bad or I could see it being the Misk
character. Okay,
>> slap it on stream. He certainly seems to be this seems
to be inappropriate. >> I've never seen moldy cheese like
this. This is the most disgusting thing in the >> Yeah,
that's gross.
>> This is gross. >> Hold on. Let's open up the Let's
open this up. >> Leave Emmy alone and throw it away. >> Okay,
I'll stay here and I won't throw it away. I got you, dude. >> Dude,
just throw it away. It's so gross.
>> We will crush them. >> I'll do the exact opposite.
I'll stay here and I'll just keep it right in your face. You
have to stare at it the whole >> Let's run them over. >> Wait,
are you winning?
>> Are you actually good?
>> No. Why you look like you're in
>> You're stressing me out.
>> Behavior. Stay sharp. It's harder to keep you alive.
>> Okay. Well, that's awkward. Hold on. Let me see what
we got from sweatpants freedom. Let's see. Let's see. We at 10K
Good job making the chat hate me more. Garbage. Don't come in
my room and leave me alone. Emmy, that wasn't my intention. I
just didn't like the bag being in my face and was getting upset.
So, I'm sorry.
we at 10K viewers.
I can't see what the actual DMs are.
Oh, did she accidentally leak her DMs?
Did she do the alt tab and she leaked their DMs? What are the
DMs they actually sent back and forth?
There should be another screenshot here, right? With the actual
DMs, cuz she would have alt tabbed at some point in this VOD.
Where's the Where's all tab? Where's it at? Let me pull the LSF
thread. Hold on. We'll pull the LSF thread. We'll get to the
bottom of this right now.
Put the link in the Discord. Okay.
Yep. Sorry. We have a quick meme from the Discord over the Miskf.
It's a mystery. Okay. Who killed Amir's
Who did it?
We We believe there's there's reason to believe it could have
been Miz. All right.
He's punching
and you never know.
Okay. Okay. Okay. I don't see it in the Discord. Wait, where
is it in the Discord? Oh, right. No, that's not it. Oh, this
is the XQC thing. Yeah, we're not doing that right now. We're
doing Miz. I thought somebody said there How do you not talk
about what's on the screen right now? [__] Misk finds
molded cheese.
This is the one moving over.
Those are the tabs. Okay. Reveals posts in his Russell post in
his offline chat that Miz turned off the power. Oh, and about
15 minutes after this happened, power went out and stream turned
off. Russell posted in his offline chat that Miz turned off the
power. Huh, bro? Miz turned out the power. No idea. Hello. Guess
I'll go back live.
Dude, Miz is an actual psycho. He's like an actual psycho. It's
crazy,
bro.
This is like a part of the DMs that got leaked.
This is like another Rust situation.
That's That's crazy, dude. Oh, it gets so much. Wait. So, this
is the thing where it could be a character and when you figure
out it's not the character like this completely makes it so that
it's not the character and he is just a psychopath who went and
turned the power off after this.
I'm trying not to lean totally into everything where I'm like
I do think Miz is a psycho, but I'm trying not to overread with
that knowledge into some of these clips and then there's just
more evidence of him more evidence of him getting more psychotic
over time. Miz and extra Emily getting extra heated with each
other. Sorry, getting heated with each other. Not extra emory
heated, but just heated.
Let me pull this.
What is this? 10 minutes with a lot of reading and interactions,
but it made me hate Miz.
>> Where's your Tesla, by the way? >> Uh, it's like
in the front, I think. >> We just
stole my car then. >> There's literally no Tesla in the
front of your my house. I swear. >> Clean. Exam clean.
>> Does someone steal my car then? >> Did you Did
you actually drive here? >> I swear to God, there's no
Tesla in my house. Uh,
>> interesting, huh?
>> Does someone steal my car? >> I don't know. It's
just there literally is no Tesla.
>> Okay, I'll check.
>> Well, now I'm scared. Why are you just pulling my bone?
but then I'm letting you know there's no >> Good job, Miz.
You did great. >> Am I getting home?
>> This is like way too much thigh. I don't need to see
the thighs, bro. We get it. We get it. You hit legs sometimes
on TRT, bro. On tren or whatever the [__] you were
on at this point. We get it. I don't need to see it,
>> It looks amazing.
>> No, this really helps. >> Okay, let's go to the
actual part where they get heated. Jesus.
>> Do what? What's she doing, bro? Just take the elevator,
>> Do what? Wait, what did he do?
>> He locked the door. >> WHAT THE [__]
MIZ? >> WAIT, WHAT HAPPENED? >> YOU BOOTED my car.
>> No, I didn't. >> Yes, you did. Emmy said you did
it. >> No, I didn't. >> Why are the Why? >> Okay.
Like, this is totally manufactured. I don't know how you could
get angry at this. This seems goofy as [__] to get
angry at. No.
Like, this is a totally contrived thing. This is just completely
scripted. It's like obviously scripted.
How'd you get angry at this?
Oh yeah, somebody pointed out the the hairline jokes. Jesus.
The hairline was having a rough go here, wasn't it?
He actually booted her car. That's why. I'm sorry, but why? Like
it's it's a bit Was she going somewhere? Maybe if she has to
go then it's like really bad.
But even if it was like not asked for, it's like you're doing
you're doing content here. I don't know. I see it as scripted
until I see evidence otherwise. Hold on. >> Wait, what
happened? >> You booted my car. We can watch a little >> Yes,
you did. Emmy said you did it. >> No, I didn't. >> WHY
ARE THERE WHY IS there like on my >> There's not. I swear.
>> Yes, there is. >> Your car wasn't out there. I
was being >> It's there AND YOU BOOTED MY CAR. >> I
swear I did not. >> Now, how do I get How do I get out?
Like, how do I leave?
>> Little does Extra Emily realize what she's putting Emiru
through by saying Emiru snitched on you. Okay, this is this is
real bad. This got real bad after Extra Emily left. Are you actually
>> Well, you booted my car. I DON'T KNOW [screaming] HOW
TO GET RID OF IT. >> I swear I didn't boot your car. I
swear
you don't believe me. >> I don't. >> I swear I didn't.
>> No, cuz I ran to Emmy and Emmy said that you did it.
>> No, I did not. >> Yes, you did. >> I thought
of doing it, but we couldn't do it cuz we couldn't find your
car. >> Well, I don't know. Like, it's literally there
booted. So, like, can you unboot
>> Bring this. >> No, unboot it. >> No, come
here. I'll show you. Oh,
>> like what the [laughter]
>> Okay. I'm I don't even know. Well, I think it's like
how how do you get rid of a boot?
>> How do you get rid of a boot? >> You have to learn
zero cycle. >> I have to learn zero cycle. >> Does
she actually get mad? It says she actually gets mad here.
>> You did this to my room. >> And your room looks
good. Yeah, >> like I booted your car.
>> It looks good. And you get back at me by booting my
car.
Yeah. Wait, why is it such a We're >> in like a prank war.
>> Big deal.
I can't tell if you're actually mad at me. >> Okay. Well,
I'll I won't be mad if you if you unboot it.
>> Just unboot. >> Wait, you do this to my room.
You You I don't say a word, I don't yell.
>> Yell. I was
>> know if she's actually trolling or not.
How am I going to get home?
>> Okay, you're not mad.
>> I mean, just >> I say sorry to everyone. >> I
This is too This is way too gay. I'm sorry. I can't I can't I
can't this with that the amiru stuff. This makes way more sense.
The extra stuff. No. Nope. Nope. Can't do it. Can't do it. Can't
continue. Can't continue pretending that that's consequential
or means anything. It's not going to work for me. All right.
Before I go into the stuff I had from a couple days ago, I'm
just going to check LSF super quick. See if there's anything
else on
Heir. Emiru makes a prediction. Oh, what the Wait, what? Julia,
wait, what is this? Julia reveals she can ruin Miskip's life
after heated argument. Then he left the room and stopped
>> You know, I could ruin your life.
It's not a fair thing to say,
>> but it's a true thing to say.
>> But to do that to someone or talk about that when you're
>> Oh, [laughter] see, there's a way different vibe right
here. The vibe I have right here is that Miskf is actually in
psychic terror for his life.
That's like I 100% read that immediately. He's not laughing.
He's not joking. He's not leaning into this. He's like immediately
like, "That's weird for you to say.
Not fair. >> He's suddenly gone to like an obvious one
HP voice. >> But I'm a better person than that.
>> It's not even fair to say that live
to say in general. >> Are you trying to >> like he's
genuinely tilted by this? >> Turn this on me.
>> I would definitely >> I'm sorry. Yes.
>> Xavier 9,900
just cheered 500 bits,
174. Just >> uh in the meantime, while they're sitting
here silently, guys, don't forget to sub, donate, okay? Add more
time to the stream. I think we're what, five subs? Sorry. No,
we're like nine subs away. Yeah, nine subs from another No, 11
subs from two more hours on the stream. I haven't chilled yet.
Guys, if you like the content, follow on every platform. Join
the Discord.
All right. Especially if you want to send links, discord.gg/jcl.
If you want to sub on kick, you can do so. It's a 955 split on
kick. If you're going to buy subs, do so on kick. Appreciate
it. Um, it's 955 split versus the 50/50, I think, on kick or
sorry, on Twitch, maybe 6040. All right, but you can sub on kick.
You can sub on Twitch. You can donate through either of the donation
links, the kickbot link or the Streamlabs link. All right. Uh,
you can give bits, you can give kicks, you can sign up for the
Patreon. Sorry, I thought there was one more thing that was going
to add more time, but also there's the Patreon. Damn, I need
to like actually script out my ad read. It's gotten progressively
worse over the past like 2 months. Anyway, guys, go ahead, donate.
Add more time to the stream. Appreciate all the support. Let's
continue with content. >> Cheer 200 bits. >> Oh,
do you know the context here? They picked tattoos for each other
and she picked something cute for him and he picked literally
the thing he promised he wouldn't do on her. Oh, well, that seems
weird. >> What's wrong, Miz? What's wrong? >> Oh,
he is like
so tilted. So beyond
>> Haha. 1,892
just cheered 200 bits. >> What's wrong? >> So what?
This is This is the tattoo he picked for her and this is the
tattoo she picked for him.
>> Wait, hold on. This isn't like these look like tattoos
on skin. They didn't get the tattoos explicitly and then reveal
what the tattoos were. Did they? Cuz if that's the case,
that's omega actually. So apparently this 0000 Pepe tattoo is
like what she didn't want. If they got the tattoos and then he
did this and she's just about that. Yeah, she has every right
to be he actually.
Bro, that's
that's bizarre,
dude. Is there Does anybody have the context here?
it's been over two days without any new nukes. Julia, please
tell us. Feed us. Uh she might just have the same nukes everyone
else had. Yo, Himster, thank you for the 500 kicks. Let's go.
W. Huge W. Uh, those haven't come through the API yet, but hit
play. >> Xavier 900 budded
300 bits. >> Uh, he's out. Is there Hold on. Who Who's
the streamer? Julia something.
Hold on.
Uh, I don't want to get rid of this window yet. Hold on.
>> To me, it's kind of a bad situation. Explanation, quite
frankly. >> Shut up, Hutch. God damn it. This guy's always
yapping. >> Julia got a viral moment in a normie Reddit.
They cooked Canoe and Arthur. Holy [__] >> I
know. It's >> I don't I don't get it. >> Wait, you
got a
>> You're like, "Oh my god, you're
>> Wait, would this be it >> to like my best friend?
Let's say I'm hanging off a cliff. >> Or is this a different
thing? This looks like a totally different thing. >> Change
the title. >> This is not about that same [__]
Okay, hold on.
Misk ends up rage baiting Julia while trying to apologize for
the tattoo. >> Ain't no way.
>> Some reason my Twitch account has bits I didn't buy.
Neat. Oh, cool. Thank you. >> Someone said mi >> This
is true to Tequila Sunset. I think
Do you want to know what I think? I think the crazy thing that
I see happening here. I think did Miz have something on NMP
because I swear like multiple people have come out like today
and been like actually NMP is like the nicest person I've ever
met and he has never done anything weird with me at all and and
NP is really cool. He's like super cool. He's like ultra cool
actually.
Yeah, Cuckoo did it and somebody else did it too. I think Kachi
did it and it's like that seems weird. Why are you guys like
pre-firing positive PR for Nick? That seems really bizarre actually.
It's very weird and sus, especially when that community doesn't
really like Nick. And like I'm not somebody who follows OTK that
much, but I just saw like multiple clips of people being like,
"Nick's never done anything weird or inappropriate with me ever."
I'm like, "Wait, why did you Is that something people say? Apppropo
of
They just they just say that.
Guys,
what guys? Just so you know, I've never I don't even want to
go into it. I I don't even want to like meme.
>> Hold on. This is her seeing the tattoo. for the first
time. [screaming]
>> Misk, you literally said, >> "Dude, she should
have she should have thrown up a you are my Aiga tattoo in this
[__] right?" Could you imagine if he reveals that
and then her reveal is it's a you are my like Mitch Jones
dude? His mental would have been gone. It would have been it
would have it been erased entirely.
>> Oh my god.
YOU LITERALLY SAID YOU WOULDN'T PUT THAT. You literally said
you wouldn't put that. You said
You said
Jesus. Those aren't light hits. The [__]
I don't know. That's kind of bizarre. That whole thing is bizarre.
I don't know. I don't know the 0000 meme. I don't know why it's
funny, but
just I could just see her doing it back to Miz. Miz not that,
you know, mentally
I don't know why he thinks it's so funny to do. Where's the kick
chat on screen? People wanted to see the tattoo before, so it
had to disappear for a second. Okay, it's back now. All right,
let let's go through the rest of the stuff I had on Miz here.
I I had some more Miz updates that we hadn't gotten a chance
to go through at all. Okay, so if you saw Cuckoo did a what do
you call it? Like a a meme on him. Okay, Cuckoo got him. Cuckoo
got him.
Now, we're going to discuss this. This was a bit of a weird one
because
I don't know that she 100% describes like salt here. It's just
like not
proven. We'll we'll read through it and you'll I'll give my thoughts
as we go along. I thought it was weird to like I don't know.
I It's It's weird. It's weird.
Okay. My miskf essay and harassment experience. Our first hookup.
I was so drunk I couldn't keep my eyes open. Originally, I was
supposed to crash on the couch, but somehow ended up in his bed.
I remember all I wanted was sleep or was to sleep, but he kept
trying to kiss me and undress me. I finally let him have it because
I was too dizzy to care anymore. And it's like, okay, I understand
that that's your perspective. I need to know like was he drunk?
Was he sober? If he's sober, it's absolutely salt. Might even
be right. That is definitely SA. I don't know how drunk the other
person was. If there's similar diminished like mental capacity
and they're hanging out together and they're like engaging this,
this can happen. And I don't necessarily hold either party like
massively responsible. Even if he isn't, it is still essay. I
would say if you are too drunk to keep your eyes open, you are
probably too drunk to remember the situation accurately, right?
Like I I'm sorry. There are a lot of things that happen here
at the same time where I'm like, "Okay, I don't know." And I
look for context clues on this. So I look for context clues on
this. I don't give a what you're saying about the law right now,
Jimmy Hennessy. I'm talking about like morally. Uh, I look for
did she think contemporaneously that this was some kind of assault,
right? When she when she woke up in the morning, did she think
this was assault? Did she think it was a problem?
Right? Or did she sort of get like did she figure this out after
Miz had his whole thing blow up? That's what I do. You know what
I mean? If you add additional context clues later,
I don't know that that's good, right? Let him have it is a crazy
way to put it. Well, I'll we can read through it and there's
it's complex. Okay. So, I'm not going to say it goes in either
way. I just don't know. I need more information. I need some
I need some contemporaneous messages. I need something to show
that she was like upset about this at the time or she saw it
as an assault at the time. She clearly didn't want to based on
her statement and he kept pressuring.
I agree. If if she is recalling this 100% correctly, right,
if she's recalling it 100% correctly, then it probably was some
kind of assault. My question would be if she felt like it was
some kind of assault, I would look for that indication because
we have some counter indications after this. Okay,
that's that's probably where it's going to go to. None of it's
going to be conclusive. We we have to keep reading. All right.
He made sure to coach me to say that it was consensual afterwards
and get the story straight because he was afraid of being cancelled.
He was so sweet at that time that we ended up having a consensual
fling afterwards. So, anything talking about this with like a
friend, anything of her sending messages to Miz where he was
saying, "Hey, just want to make sure that this was like all good,
right? Anything like this that could back this up, I would want
to see." All right.
Now, I'm telling you, as this as this sounds, it could be assault.
It could be something that where it's like it was dubious consent
and she sort of has retroactively labeled it as assault in her
head.
I'm not going to say it's like clear consent. It's obviously
like dubious consent, right? But again, you'd have to know what
Msk was like, what his state was. If if I could see messages
of him like messaging her or if he'd messaged people about it,
right? If I could see any indication that this is what people
thought at the time, I
yeah, I would be interested.
Anyway, after our fling ended, he started terrible rumors about
me, telling people I was manipulative, bad, and an awful human.
He would tell people that I cut myself during and that I was
crazy. I would love to see any third party backing up of this.
Like somebody coming out and saying this is what Miz told me,
right?
That's what I would I would like to see that he was like spreading
this rumor. I would hear the most awful rumors from people I
had just met even years later. He would continue talking about
me long after we were no we no longer interacted.
This made me never reach out to people anymore. I was mortified
of the rumors he'd spread and depressed over what people thought
of me. Lucari's witness to the depression misgiv caused me. He's
also witnessed to the harassment I experienced long after the
fling was over. So yeah, I would want to see what Lucari is saying
about this as well. Okay.
During my relationship with Lucari, he'd regularly talk about
me and constantly tell Lucari that he doesn't know the real Cuo.
Cuko, never know how to say that name. He tried poisoning our
relationship the whole time. He would plant ideas into Lucari's
head to start fights. After the relationship with Lucari ended,
Miz upped the even more. Lucari noted that it took it looked
like Miz was actively trying to ruin my reputation. I would hear
how everyone in Austin hates me because of what Miz would say.
I think Emir is super brave for coming up with her story. I struggle
with posting this as I don't want to be associated with or tied
to him at all, but I want to corroborate her story with my personal
hell Misgif kindly gifted to
So to me, like what I what I lean towards here is that this was
like a dubious thing that she felt comfortable with, comfortable
enough that hey, we were going to have a fling afterwards and
it's okay. And then after he started revealing that he was like
a total piece of [__] this started like grading in
her mind and it went from dubious to like obviously violative.
That's the read I have. I understand if people get upset by that
read. Okay, see here. Love you. It's just a lot of support. Sorry
you went through this.
Uh, I do think
I I know nothing about Miskip's character that makes me doubt
this, right? Like I could easily be convinced of this like further.
I'm just saying that right now I don't see additional evidence
of this at all. I would want to see some people like backing
this up, but there's nothing in Misk's character
that
No, I meant
Reuben, Ruben, I don't see anything in Misk's character that
makes me doubt this happened. Right. It's not like I'm I'm not
going like, "Oh, no, that doesn't seem like Msk. No, that seems
like all this probably lines up with who Msk is."
Just trying to like not let myself get baited by what I know
about him into saying, "Oh, obviously he did this." Automod didn't
like somebody's message. Uh-oh. What was the message? I'll just
allow it. [__] it.
I think it's probably one of those things. A girl might brush
off like, "Ah, he's a good dude, but that made a mistake." But
then it comes out he's a piece of so you look back more maliciously.
Yeah. Yeah. And not even like maliciously. It's she probably
sees things like, oh, how he approaches other women, how he treats
her after the fact, and she's willing to like look at that and
go, "Oh, suddenly when I gave him the benefit of the doubt before
this, it's like now it's kind of flipping right now. It's flipping."
And it's like, "Okay, I gave him like a benefit of the doubt
in one or two places when he was telling the story." And without
that benefit of the doubt, wow, that situation from before looks
really bad. Yeah, I could see that. Do you think Emiru neglected
the rabbits or is that a lie?
Um, I think Emiru almost certainly neglected her rabbits. I don't
know if it's anywhere near as bad as Msk is saying. Um, I'm guessing
she was like depressed and didn't take care of her rabbits. I'm
guessing that most of the time she's an excellent caretaker of
her rabbits and that there was something going on where she was
like depressed and there was like weeks or months of her not
taking care of the rabbits. I don't I don't think she's like
a rabbit murderer. I don't think she's like an evil person. I
think almost certainly it seems like there there's some backup
for the idea that she probably didn't take care of those rabbits.
And I think I think a lot of people want to push back against
that and say like no, there's no way that happened.
Uh okay.
I' I'd be I'd wait to hear what Maya said cuz Miz Miz invoked
Mia directly. He said Mia said these rabbits are being like are
being neglected horribly and this is like horrible, right? Doesn't
really justify it. Doesn't justify it at all.
But again, you'd have to know what happened to the rabbits, how
long the mis the mistreatment occurred for. There's like a lot
of things that could have happened with the rabbits. I I tend
to think it looks bad for Emmy no matter what. It just doesn't
absolve misk in any way.
That taco cat post is pretty detailed. Uh, okay. We could I mean,
send me the post. Send me the post. We'll evaluate the rabbit
genocide. Okay. We're going to do a little bunny holocaust revisionism.
You know, don't you guys love bunny holocaust revisionism? That's
a joke, by the way. That's a joke. That's a joke. It's just a
joke.
What is the taco cat post? Taco cat emu.
Taco cat Emiru. Is there a Hold on. I keep it taco. Okay. Uh
Emiru has been one of my best friends for 10 years. At first,
I thought this wasn't needed. It's insane to me to see some people
are actually calling her an animal abuser or bunny killer on
here the past few days and stating it as a fact. She goes way
beyond for her pets. And in my view, Miskip's claim are claims
are easy to refute. To me, he often seems to avoid accountability.
He has always come off as highly inauthentic.
Okay, so first I would want to basically hear why 11 rabbits
died. Why did they think 11 rabbits died, right? We're going
to need to see why 11 rabbits died
for sure. So, I personally suspect the cage was recorded after
she left back in early July 2024 and kept in case it could be
used against her later. Seeing this decision to share the video
now instead of back then, it seems to me he may have filmed it
and kept the video for leverage,
Shouldn't that be pretty easy to figure out? I feel like that
should be really easy to figure out for anyone here.
Uh, what actually happened? To the best of my knowledge, Emily
left the cage behind because she was moving out to a new house
alone and took her bunnies with her. It made no sense for her
to clean the cage that week. She was focusing on moving away
from a bad environment ASAP and she planned to buy a new one
for her new place. I helped her build the new cage at her place
last summer. I have pictures of that day because while I was
building it, her cat Cheddar was playing with my rings all day.
So, I was teasing him with them and he climbed into the cage.
First two pictures. Okay, this is like totally fine. What about
the allegation that she left the rabbits out in the heat with
without water for long periods of time,
Yeah, this also doesn't I trust me, I already said this before
we even started reading this post. I have no doubt that for most
of the time she took great care of her rabbits. Like that's not
really in contention here. I'm positive she would have taken
great care of her rabbits at different points.
This is an allegation that they were neglected for a period of
time. Rabbits are dirty animals. They poop all the time in abundance.
If you want a super clean cage with zero poop visible, you'll
end up cleaning it multiple times every day every week. Most
owners do it only once or twice a week. It's normal for there
to be poop. The poop is very dry, so it doesn't have any smell.
There's no inherent issue with this. Rabbits poop 200 to 300
pellets each day. Oh, okay. Each day. Uh, [screaming] yeah. I
feel like there's probably I feel like the the poop is very dry,
so it doesn't have any smell is like a bit of a cope. Come on,
man.
I I I
feel like there's a lot of like horrifyingly smelling personal
spaces that just
like Come on, man.
Come on, dog. Anyway,
I only know this because when you're around someone for so long
that takes care of their buns, then you tend to learn a lot about
bunnies. Why is the cage extra dirty and why does it have bugs
in it? Emily didn't see a reason to clean it again if she was
moving out and not bring it with her. So, if I had to guess,
it was unattended for a couple weeks or after or or more after
she left. People were free to toss it away. The bugs likely showed
up after the cage was left dirty for some amount of time. She
left them to die. No, she didn't. Two of the bunnies, Kiwi and
Honey, are with her last picture. And the third one, Bean, passed
away last year because of medical problems. Blackside one, third
picture. She was over one year old in this picture.
Okay, these are three. These are these are three. Two of which
didn't die. We've we've analyzed why one bunny died. Bean was
5 plus years old when she died. She passed away late June 2024.
It was due to a seizure. She always had health problems. When
she was a baby, she would randomly pass out and stop moving for
a bit. The first day Bean had passed out when she was a baby,
Emily immediately ended stream and drove 3 hours to the nearest
open animal hospital because it was a Sunday and most of them
nearby were closed. The vet said her heart would randomly stop
pumping because her heart nodes weren't developed correctly.
Years later, the vet said she uh things should be okay now that
she's older, but she then later went uh later on would again
start passing out randomly and waking up. The heart problems
never really went away. It just reappeared later as she got older.
Maybe the stressful environment brought it back. I don't know.
She she had complications since birth. That's how she died. A
few of her original bunnies later on were learned to have very
poor genetics due to the breeder she got them from years ago
pre 2017 2018.
We didn't learn this till the bunnies bred later on in their
lives. Till the bunnies bred later on in their lives. And we
learned it over time.
That's also how Mocha died in September. In September 2021, 6
to 10 months old. Her mom Po, 6 years old, passed away a few
months after giving birth to Mocha. Unfortunately, Mocha inherited
poor genetics from Po, which caused her to pass away early. It's
unfair for Miskip to mention none of this. However, not surprising
for someone who didn't mention any of their names to begin with,
nor their history.
All right. I don't know.
Okay, so we've got one died because it was old and ill, and two
more died because they were ill.
Okay,
Emily has cared for multiple bunnies over the years. If they
had any medical issues or were found to have a birth defect,
she'd spend thousands of dollars to give them the best care as
fast as possible. She tried to give her bunnies the fullest and
longest lives possible, even when she was told it wasn't worth
it financially. This was before she got into streaming, too.
And she is and she is the same way now. They're not an accessory,
as some people would try to imply on this site. It is hard to
believe an animal abuser would do this. Loud noises can lead
to extreme fear, heart attacks, and other health problems like
gastrointestinal stasis. It's important to provide a calm environment
in a safe, quiet hiding place to minimize their stress. Veterinarian
articles about rabbits.
Honestly, I don't think this dude, this is going to be all Oh,
I didn't realize people actually pulled this one. I I thought
this was just memes in the Discord. I me'd about this cuz it
sounded so silly. Okay, but it is actually the real thing. Honestly,
I didn't think of this point until people brought it up here,
but it's true that a lots of loud noises and stress can impact
the bunnies. They're weak creatures. It's why people don't recommend
them as pets because if you get attached to them easily, you
have to be prepared for premature deaths. In the clips that from
that period, Misk's behavior during this time came with a lot
of yelling, door slamming, wall punching, and other loud outbursts.
Loud noises and stress can exacerbate a rabbit heart rabbit heart
conditions.
Does nobody like I'm sorry. This is like order. This is level
one. Okay. This is first order thinking.
What are you saying? So she moved all of these bunnies that are
liable to drop dead at the sound of anything stressful into a
house with Bruce, Russell, Mizkiff, like all of these OTK streamers
who scream all the time. That's what she did. That sure sounds
up, dude. That sounds crazy.
How do you think this
Should we move them into a streamer house? What? Okay. Anyway,
due to this, I don't think Okay. Loud noises and stress can exacerbate
rabbit heart conditions. Due to this, I don't think he considered
the bunny's well-being until it benefited him as leverage. Rabbits
are prey animals. They're very sensitive and fragile creatures.
I do think this is true. I think this is obviously true that
he didn't care about them until he could use them as leverage.
Saying they died because of no food and no water is completely
false. Or that she left them outside in 100°ree weather. She
lets the bunnies into the rest of the house and sometimes backyard
to roam around. That's healthy for them. She doesn't keep them
in cages or play pens 24/7. He keeps referring to them as rabbits,
but he doesn't even know any of their names.
Okay, not a single mention. Msk not caring about these rabbits
was obvious when he went to use them as leverage and didn't take
care of them. Right, Msk. This is all built into Miskip's allegation
that he's only bringing this up now because Amir ratted him out,
so he's going to rat her out. It's obvious he never cared about
the rabbits. It's obvious he's like a total psychopath. He's
a crazy person, right? I don't know why we're saying, "Oh, it's
obvious." Yeah, I know. We all know that doesn't make it okay.
He keeps Unfortunately, at this point, we're going to have to
do Does anybody have those like um the ground penetrating radar?
Can we do some Canadian,
you know, some Canadian residential school ground or residential
school graveyard searches? All right, we need to look for the
bunny corpses in the ground. Can somebody We need to get one.
All right, we need to get one. We need to find the bunny graveyard.
Where is it? Okay. Anyway, I got the impression he sees animals
as opportunity. Me, Emily, and a few other friends were watching
Alien Romulus last September. It's not often that we all spend
time together as a group IRL cause cuz everyone is split across
the country. What happens? She tells me she has to leave, but
she'll be back fast because Mskiff needs help with a stray cat
that he found at the airport and he has no one else to help him.
It felt performative to me when he posted and later deleted the
cat photo on Twitter. She missed out on the entire movie and
showed up 30 minutes after it was over. I told her it seemed
to me he was just using the stray cat as a way to interact with
her and get her to hang out with him. The stray cat ran away,
no surprise, and nothing was achieved.
It sounds like this person hated Biscuit from the beginning.
It sounds like she just hate she just despised Msk, which hey,
maybe she just has really good senses. But
I'm sorry. The stray cat ran away, no surprise, and nothing was
achieved. Emily had told him earlier we would be in town that
week, so I suspect he might have used that information to try
to minimize her time with us. At that moment, it seemed he still
had a lot of influencer over influence over her at the time.
I think that's everything I got to say about the buns. I know
I've been criticized for being vocal in numerous drama situations
in the past. I think it's important for me to speak up because
I have always been in a position in my life or in life where
my livelihood isn't at risk for speaking out against people who
might be a a detriment to our community. I've never relied on
streaming for a living and never will. Not any not everyone can
say the same. I don't even stream anymore. My passion isn't there
anymore. It's somewhere else now. TLDDR can't believe I have
to. So this is basically Creger. What detail here absolves Emiru?
Creger. I need you to come out. Come out right now. What detail
absolves Emiru from anything said. I I need to know what detail
was given here.
I need Emirou to come out herself and say, "No, he's lying about
when those videos were taken or back this up." A third party
who wasn't there, right? A third party who wasn't there saying
that. That's
total bull.
I want one of the people who lived in the house, right? I want
one of the people who lived in that house at the time to come
out and say this is impossible that this didn't happen. And I
have not seen that. And there are a ton of people with all the
clout in the world to gain right now who could come out and say,
"Oh, there's no way I lived in that house and Emry took great
care of those rabbits.
Show me one of them." Every single one of them massively incentivized
to do so. Every single one of them shutting the
Which means one of two things. Okay. Either this is a 20 streamer
situation. I'm taking 20 streamers down situation. and they've
all got blackmailed that Miz knows about or
Amir did some Russell responded and said he didn't know anything
about what was happening. That sounds even worse to me. Uh guys,
I was deaf, dumb, and blind. I'm basically Helen Keller. Okay,
I'm the black Helen Keller. Look at me. I'm Russell. Good one,
Russell.
That tells me again that he feels like most of this that they're
saying about each other is probably true and he doesn't want
any part of it. He doesn't want to be he doesn't want to be caught
in the crossfire. Okay. He doesn't want to be in the blast radius.
When was the first bunny death? Did all 11 die within the fouryear
span? I don't know. And by the way, I don't think this is like
Emiru broadly being abusive to rabbits over time, like for for
like a very long period of time. It sounds like she had like
a period where she just wasn't doing anything and that it was
a problem and I'm guessing it wasn't a problem at different points
or stopped being a problem, right? But but I've not seen I'm
just telling you my skitso senses tingle when I see nobody who
lived in that house coming out to go, "Oh no, she took great
care of her rabbits." Esfan seemed to be fine with Emiru coming
over. When Msk was feeling like when Msk was super emotionally
dregulated, was screaming at her. She'd go over to Esan's house.
He'd let her stay there. Why wouldn't Esfan know? Msk ruined
her mental health. Maybe
there were rabbits dying before she moved. Oh, were there?
Anyway, we'll keep we'll keep reading.
Listen, you know who I need to do? You know who I need to talk
to? I need to talk to some of those OTK like ship people. Okay?
I guarantee you those people were like tracking rabbits over
time. I guarantee you there's like some there's some
corkboard chart that some one of these people did showing every
one of the rabbits when they last appeared on stream, when they
first appeared on stream. He knows every rabbit. He knows all
of their names. He's got their entire timeline laid out and he
would just know the answer. Bunnies are among the simplest creatures
to take care of. If you can't take care of bunnies, you're probably
at risk of dying to neglect yourself. Okay. Well, there was a
bedding pool 100%. Uh, I don't know what that was about.
I'm not saying she has a poor handling or she has poor handling
of rabbits. Just a long history of raising them with deaths involved
going back 10 years. Maybe if Hassan's dog was a full news full
week's news cycle, two weeks, by the way, poor rebeller. I expect
the bunny butcher
to be at least 10 days. [laughter]
Uh, dude, if brother, if all I know, okay, is if were a 10 out
of 10 woman, that guy wouldn't even be in a history book. Okay,
that guy, they'd just be like, "Oh, they fooled him. They f they
fooled her." Okay,
that wouldn't even be in a history book. We wouldn't even know
his name her name.
That's just true. Okay, that's just that's facts. All right.
Can't believe I have to explain cuz I see some people on here
rolling with it as if it's a fact. There is no rabbit abuse or
details
I took my time writing this to make sure it reflects only what
I've personally seen, heard, and experienced and articulate it
in an easy to follow format. So again, this is like Asminold's
thing, right? This is this is people should understand that this
is not good to do, right? You could say some things like this,
but to say in this at the same time that it's proof she didn't
do any of this or she's never neglected her animals, you objectively
weren't there most of the time. You're like, when I was around
her, she took really good care of her animals for like the 0.001%
001% of her life I was involved in in the past 10 years.
You you are saying nothing. This is like a totally inconsequential
statement of
It's inane babble. Anyway,
these are my personal observations and opinions based on what
I've personally seen and experience from my own perspective.
Others may disagree.
So, this the first two were
pictures of what? I thought these were supposed to be rabbit
pictures. Oh, no. This is the this is cheddar.
Hold on. first two pics.
Uh, I helped her build the new cage at her place last summer.
I have pictures of that day because I was building it. Her cat
Cheddar was playing with my rings all day, so I was teasing him
with them in his cage. So, this is proof that she hung out with
Emiru for a day.
Um, this is another picture of a rabbit. Black side one, third
picture.
This is one of the rabbits. This is another two of the rabbits.
And then, do we not have anything after that? Nope, it's just
the four. Okay.
Wait, why can't I see any of the um any of the replies or anything
here? What's going on? I keep it taco.
Don't talk as if you know anything. All you did was try to spread
disinformation about my friend to get impressions on your for
your only fans business at Haley Q. Amiru could be a victim and
an animal abuser at the same time. By the way, we can acknowledge
that Misk is a trash person and feel upset for her while also
acknowledging that her negligence killed multiple rabbits. I
mean, that's the allegation. I just know that there's like eight
people who know the truth to this and they're not coming forward.
Time to nut up or shut up. All right. Actually, no. That's the
wrong one. It's time for these people to speak. Please, for the
love of God, would any of these people speak?
Tons of people who live there. They're not saying. But also,
Miz video was also misleading because it had no rabbit, just
a dirty cage that was most likely getting cleaned.
Okay.
So, I know. So, Ms. Kev's story is his brother was super off
about how the rabbits were treated, right? And that his brother
was mad. So, if his brother came there and said, "This is disgusting.
Get these rabbits out of here and clean this up." And then took
a video of the cage,
what is not included in Miskf's story? What is weird about Msk's
story? And what makes what makes it seem suspicious? I think
he should probably post some of his text with his brother though
for you to have like a solid opinion on this. Uh, at the time
is crazy to me. So, I've never genuinely hated every word and
movement someone did. Tommy in it says Misk is the worst person
he's met last year. Okay.
Mi mischief is psychotic, so he could just be making this whole
thing up. It's It's possible. It could be abuse, Jacob. Yeah,
sure. Well, I don't really What do you call it? I don't super
care. I'm just I'm like dispassionately analyzing.
I'm not like emotionally involved, you know? Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Ah. Hold on. What am I trying to do here?
Give me a second. Is this not working? Hello.
What the hell?
There we go. Here
we go. Here we go. Okay. All right. Let's continue on with
with all of this. All right. So, there's there's the bunny post.
I don't know if there's other stuff for the uh the bunny post.
Oh, Emmy makes a prediction. Hold on. >> Hello, Nim and
happy new year. Uh my highlight of 2024 was all of the cosplay
streams I did and having lots of cool guests on my stream like
Pokey, Hassan, and Norafon, and a bunch of other cool people.
and in 2025.
Uh, so most of my friends have already been cancelled, which
means that there's not many more left, so I'm happy for them
for that. >> that's good enough, right? >> That's
crazy.
That's crazy, chat.
Amazing stuff. What did Challen,
you're out of here. >> All right, guys. Uh, you guys got
to unlock that bathroom. I It's still Oh, wait. You think I'm
trolling? Oh, I'm walking out. No, you I'm going to watch you
walk out. >> No, I'm walking out. >> Let's go. I'll
walk you out. Walking
I'm going to follow you out.
>> I'm getting my phone, >> bro. Was toxic right.
the house. So, I'll see you guys never actually. [__]
stream. >> I'm I'm going to go and my setup, my keyboard,
my mouse, my wife, my
opening.
You done the stream. >> YOU KNOW WHAT? [__]
YOU, MAN. I DON'T EVEN NEED YOU ANYWAYS. [__]
>> WAIT, she she was actually sad. >> Wait, she was
actually sad, >> bro. I There are a lot of like OTK clips
that See, this is the thing is
they like do content for people who didn't have social lives
and so people can never interpret. It's like I don't know. This
clip is sent and I have no idea what it's supposed to be. >> I
go a little too far, man. >> This is like nothing. >> Oh
god. >> Oh, go back. Cry. I don't give a [__]
>> It's Trump's America. I don't give a [__]
ABOUT WOMEN. >> HEY LARI, CAN YOU GET MY JOB FREE? >> OH,
you'll be a [__] Remember, she just ruined everything
and she [__] >> Wow.
Crazy. How do people watch this? I have no idea. I like like
honestly there's a lot of good clips or whatever, but these are
not them.
Okay, I'm still not to all the other stuff from the Misg updates.
So, we read the Cuko uh analysis. We read the Oh, there's these
ones. Zezy told me some stuff about these ones, I think. Oh,
[__] me. Hold on. This is the Iumei the Aayumi thing.
Oh, I don't have God damn it. How do I find this? Just give me
a second. I have to go grab
I have to go grab this thing again in my own DMs. One second.
Why did this not work? Here we go. This is apparently this person
said they had really bad interactions with Msk a long time ago.
So 2024 Msk called himself the master of cover-ups for 4 years.
I wonder how long he can cover up my assault from Paxis 2019.
I'm not going to keep this on my profile for long. Just long
enough for the right people to see it. Then she responds to somebody.
[__] Hold on. I need to pop like this so that you
guys can see it. I have proof, but I'm also not going to just
post it and dox myself. I don't I don't apologize, hun. I don't
have the trauma from it anymore. It's just the light of events
or just the light of events recently kind of stirring up something
inside. Oh, so this would be about um this would be about the
Adriana Lee stuff, right?
I understand not wanting to dox, of course, but is there no way
to censor sensitive details? If your allegation is true, then
it makes it shows that he didn't just make one a one-off mistake,
but as a serial offender. Stuff like that should be brought to
light where possible. No, I have proof and gathering more, but
it's been a struggle since my old Twitter was deleted. But there's
three people in the Twitch community and two of Austin's who
have had the evidence for a while now. I just asked not to release
it publicly on my behalf.
To be fair, the allegation isn't that he has her. It's that he
covered it up. No, it's both.
No, it's not. I mean, unless she's making her own.
Yeah. No, no, no. He covered the her allegation from 2019 and
then in 2022 she's bringing it up with respect to the Adrian
Lee drama obviously right I don't have the trauma from it anymore
it's just the light of events recently kind of stirring up something
so light light of events she's basically saying the events recently
this was the misk call this was the Adriana Lee stuff right so
she's saying based on this all coming to light I I'm like talking
about this from 2019 all right
and then she posted October 25th 2025 I said it. I said it. She
said it, guys.
She said it.
I'm trying to get all the misk stuff out there. Okay. All the
allegations. I haven't seen anything else about this.
I I haven't seen any other allegations of assault. Okay, these
were the ones.
Quick miz quick miz clip. As gold reaction apparently misk crashing
out. >> What's wrong?
No, I just stare at a couple like I my brain uses so much work
and then I charge for like 30 seconds. I'm good in your brain.
>> I'm sorry. >> Got him, [laughter] >> dude.
Oh, what a
what a spaz. What a weird spaz. I've never seen anything like
that before, [laughter] bro. Somebody get this guy a trackpad.
Okay,
it's embarrassing. Why don't you have a trackpad, bro? >> Oh
god. Right. Why don't you have a trackpad? It's so easy. >> It's
like, "Oh, great. My boyfriend's embarrassing me in front of
my friends
>> For what?
>> For not.
>> I'm [__] done. >> I'm done.
>> The theatrics
can luckily
it does look like >> Who knew that Mizkiff and Darius were
just literally the same person the whole
>> What a shocking revelation. Oh my god.
Who does this [__]
you're so extra. Bro, you're doing too much. For real. For real.
>> I feel like the reason this is clipped long is he does
something else that makes it worse. Let's see. What did he do?
You missed it. >> She trying to talk to the cat. >> Got
some water. >> I've got some water for you. Yeah. >> Someone
said plus 50 testosterone.
>> the sound of that. >> He's kind of just getting
cooked if you missed it. He just dumps these two things of water.
He like kind of gets cooked and he just like decides to dump
these two things of water and walk away. >> Got him.
He's sorry. Three things of water. He tries to dump three things
of water out and he just walks away.
>> Bro, Emir does seem to have the reactions of somebody
who's like done with this. Like totally done with this in every
possible way. Dude, how did how did this guy evade detection
as like as this kind of weirdo? This is the weirdest thing I've
ever seen.
I'm just going to dump out the water on the table. I I That's
how I feel like, you know, his was botted to hell. And all of
these people must be like 95% bots watching, right? Cuz nobody
clipped this and nobody was like, "Oh, this is weird. We're not
going to watch anymore." It's just all bots. Like nobody was
actually paying any attention to any of this at any point. or
nobody with, you know, some amount of sentence.
These are the two the two threads now. This is the one big thing
that we didn't cover and we need to cover now. Okay.
So, Misk went to his offline chat 3 days ago. It was the day
after his stream. Okay.
And he threw a lot of logs in there. Now, I can't remember if
these are top down or bottom up. I think it looks top down. It
looks like it's top down. Okay, so hey,
don't harass people. Come on, just chill. I'm getting people
saying this place is freaking out. You know, I know I've done
a lot of wrong in my years on Twitch and that I wish I could
just take back or that I wish I could take back. But a lot of
you know I've been working on myself for the past year hard.
It's not weird. People don't know because people don't watch
me. I've been in therapy for almost a year. been working on myself
and I want to continue to do so. I'm not going to go back to
the place I once was. I was depressed and taking every type of
drug possible to short-term fix my brain.
And in doing that, I hurt myself more. I was on steroids because
I thought I would fix myself or thought it would fix myself.
I was taking shrooms every day to fix my brain, but that destroyed
me. Never take shrooms when depressed, like ever. I would take
my head and push it into my pool, trying to drown myself on
So for two years, all I did is take shrooms to fix my brain and
steroids to fix myself. And all I can think in all of this is
like he was just projecting when he made his statement to Aryasaki.
Okay, you guys remember this statement he made that Aryasaki
talked about?
This is just projection. One of the reasons Byron killed himself
was because he was jealous of me. I think Mskiff was incredibly
jealous of Byron and decided to try to follow his path or something
like he could he could somehow get his career back if he or or
even like some respect. I don't even know. Okay.
But why did he why did he have to like copy Byron's flow? That's
it. Right. He just totally copied his flow. I don't know about
the steroids for Reckful, but definitely the shrooms. I tried
acid and that backfired in doing that. I know I [__]
up so bad and hurt so many people around me. I lashed out. I
was angry and out of my mind. I did take steroids. They gave
me insane anger issues. You could tell when I was because I don't
want you guys to know I was because I didn't want you guys to
know I was. It was embarrassing. I got off steroids about a year
ago fully. You can't just get off it. I take full accountability
for who I was. I wish I didn't go for drugs and really focused
on fixing myself. I went for short-term fixes and it backfired.
But I am proud of my progress this last year. I'm proud of who
I'm becoming or who I've been becoming. I feel more normal than
ever. It doesn't change what I did in the past. I understand
people will see that and not want to come back or not want to
or not talk to me. Every time I close my eyes since 2022 while
I was in Austin, I envision different ways of killing
Wow. Now I like I could feel some amount of I don't know empathy
for this.
Like it just it doesn't fix like the bad things you did. And
I think if you're attacking a bunch of people now,
it it just doesn't seem like you either get to be the guy who
says, "I'm gonna stream and I'm gonna leak something new every
day and I'm gonna go to war with these people." You get to be
that guy or you get to be the guy who's like, "Guys, I was on
steroids and I had drug problems and it was all issues for me,
man." You get to pick one of those guys. You don't get to be
both of those guys at the same time. Okay? You don't get to do
the, "Oh, I'm I'm like going to giga chat. I can go through all
of this. Everybody else, I'm a lone wolf. I'm fixed. I'm good
to go. I'll leak everything right now. You don't get to be that
guy while also going, "Guys, I I was kind of bad and I did drugs
and I want you all to forgive me." There are two wolves inside
of him, but they don't get to both come out at the same time,
Ozel. Okay? He can't use them both for the same situation. You
can't be this meek lamb. You can't be the small bean and the
like the lion who's going to eat all the all of your enemies.
All right? You can't do both at the same time. It's goofy. It's
a goofy attempt goofy thing to attempt to do.
Oh, apparently Canoot finds Msk's mushrooms and throws them all
out cuz he thinks they're rotten. Yeah, exactly. Sweatpants freedom.
>> It's It's the
It's the vegetables that that they had.
>> It's the vegetable.
>> Can's body is a temple. Okay, Kenut's body is a temple.
He would never put any elicit substances into his body. Okay,
we all know this. Oh, we all know this. That's obviously true.
He doesn't know what those are at all.
So, I I it's it's just like it's bizarre to to do this one and
then threaten to leak at the same time. Leak the stuff about
Emiru's rabbits.
I will agree with everybody. By the way, the the question with
the Emiru rabbit thing is not at all about Msk. None of it makes
Msk better. None of it absolves Msk of any of his behavior. It
literally just makes him look worse while hurting Emiru. Like,
he makes himself look worse and hurts Emir at the same time.
Miz gave this girl a panic attack in a restaurant if you haven't
seen it yet. Okay, let's check it out real quick. While we're
in the Miz section of the segment. Okay,
we'll check it out.
>> No. No. What I'm about to say, you're probably going
to be really really mad at me for probably the maddest you've
ever been at me.
>> But this tastes like uh Chef Boyardd
to me.
It reminds me of Chef >> Boy RD.
>> That was my real honest first.
>> I'll be real. This is like the best Misk content. Like
solo Misk content I've ever seen. >> How did someone in
chat say they they said that before you said it? >> They
said watch. She's going to say it tastes like Chef Boyardd.
It kind of does though. Like taste it and think about that.
>> Just just imagine. Just taste it and think about that.
>> It's good.
>> But it really reminds me of Chef.
>> Just tell Just imagine the canned like
>> I love chef. >> Okay, just imagine it. I'm telling
you. It's like the the salt and tomato combo.
What do you see? I
I you guys need like a hold on who sent this because I do thank
you guys for for like sending stuff Billy Joe Bush but like this
is so low grade compared to like all the other stuff. I don't
know why I feel like
I is this is this something where does he say something that's
mean? He said he made her cry. I'm like skipping way forward.
Was this crying? She looks totally fine here. Okay, now she leaves.
>> Had chef boy. >> I have not. >> Okay. Well,
cuz she is running away right now because she tried to claim
this tastes like chef. >> None of this is like I'll find
the clip.
Here's the link. Trimmer's date has a panic attack.
>> Can I go home?
>> I want to go home, [laughter] too.
>> We are not a good match. We are not a good match. We
are not a good match. We are not a good match.
This
[laughter]
>> Why are you crying? >> Because I'm having a panic
attack. >> Are you really?
>> Is this like Msk's superpower is like he's actually
like he's actually putting people in like like horrible situations
where they feel like totally. But his power is like making it
seem to everybody else like it's obviously scripted. Like through
his reactions, you're like, "Oh, this isn't real." Like he's
just a total psycho. So, so he seems like he's not having no
problems.
>> Yes, I am. [laughter]
>> Why is she crying? Because he keeps like making her
he keeps putting her on the spot. Like she said something, he
keeps pressing her on how stupid it was like over and over again.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He was goofing on her and she just couldn't
handle him like kind of pressing on it.
>> I'm shaking. [laughter] Did
>> you actually do this?
>> Yeah, I know. I know. I know. He called the manager
over and I know I know he
>> Okay,
[laughter] I think that's Is that everything on the Misk stuff?
I think that's all of it. There's like one more thread. What
was this? This Misg subreddit talking about it. For two years,
all I did was take shrooms to fix my brain and steroids to fix
myself.
Highly pathetic considering how he was banning people for calling
him on his steroid use. I forgot his backup. Whoops.
How does this look? It's still not all the way there.
There we go.
Uh, it's straight up insecurity. He's prided himself many times
on the fact that his community knew him so well, but took offense
when people hyper analyzed him and came to the correct conclusions.
Fing out about his or finding out about his relationship, substance
abuse, his mental health problems. Member of this members of
this community have been pointing it out for years. Of course,
many didn't know how severe his problems were, nor were 100%
accurate in their statements about him. and his situations. But
usually Miz would just dismiss anything that hit close to home
and you'd end up getting labeled a skitso. Also, I'm not saying
it's okay to do this with online personalities in general, but
specifically to Miz he's lived his life through streaming. It's
not hard to it's it's hard not to point out things he clearly
gets emotional about or that he can barely hide. He made a parasocial
community he has to live with the consequences of it. Yeah. Yeah.
Obviously, this is like 100% correct. There's people who are
like, "Oh, why do these skits think they can psychoanalyze me?"
It's like cuz you live 8 hours a day in front of the same people
who watch you every single day. Literally, your own mother couldn't
psycho analyze you better than this. Like you're you're totally
open the whole time. Yeah. You have people who watch everything
you do every single day. They never miss a single moment. Of
course they can psychoanalyze you. If only you took accountability
instead of drugs. Like if both shrooms and acid gave you a bad
experience. Maybe that's the universe telling you you're
Oh no. Mrs. Sub is turned on him, guys.
Mrs. The sub is totally turned on him.
Crazy that he saw his friend Reckful taking shrooms and getting
ultra depressed from it and himself and said, "Yeah, I'm going
to take shrooms to fix myself." Dude also thought he will be
fixed if he gets jacked with steroids. Everything to avoid accepting
that if you want to make changes, you need to make changes in
your life and not just fill hollowess with half measures. Dr.
K even said this after his last talk with Msk.
Oh, Dr. K was >> frequently when I do something to fix
the problem, I'm actually reinforcing the insecurity. I'm not
actually digesting the insecurity. I'm doing something to bypass
it. If I feel ashamed of myself because I'm poor and I >> This
is like uh body dysmorphia, right? You can't fix body dysmorphia
in the gym or with plastic surgery or anything. It's like body
dysmorphia is like you have to overcome that, right? That's like
how people end up getting plastic surgery addiction. They're
like really insecure about something and then they get plastic
surgery and then it doesn't quite fix it perfectly and realistically
like it was a psychological thing. Like it was sort of made up
in your head to begin with. So you get the plastic surgery, it
doesn't fix anything and just gets worse.
Can't help but agree with Mr. Well, we didn't even watch any
of the live therapy. This is just his conclusion. >> Become
rich. I can still carry the shame with me.
And this is why people will get addicted to plastic surgery.
You'll see this in clinical. >> Let's go. Let's go. Manifestations.
This can result in things like anorexia nervosa or body dis.
>> I'm like basically a PhD in psychology.
like more or less
>> definitely not >> I am unhappy with myself let
me fix something on the outside to fix something on the inside
doesn't quite work like that >> whatever Dr. K says do
the opposite Dr. K gives really good advice like 99% of the time
and people actually just don't understand anything he says. He
unfortunately the 1% of the time is cataclysmic. But listen,
other than that 1% of the time it's [music] totally cat it's
it's good. It's like a lot of good stuff there. Okay? Like 95%
of the time it's good. 5% of the time is 4% of the time it's
whatever. 1% of the time it's like totally cataclysmic. It's
totally up that he says the thing he he says. Okay. But is he
a doctor? He is literally a doctor. Yes.
bro makes 30-minute videos to explain simple ideas to children.
Yeah, that's like every professional in like every field ever.
You understand that? Like the more you understand a subject,
the better you get at dumbing it down for people.
And like there is an art to doing that. I People are like, "Oh,
this person who makes millions of dollars doing this thing has
absolutely no talent and and they're not good at it." And it's
like, "No, that's probably not true. I I that's probably not
true. I don't know. That's a Fineman's thing or something, right?
I don't know. It's just generally true, right? If somebody understands
something really well, they get better at at explaining things,
right? Or they they should be getting better at explaining things.
That's like something you should optimize for
anyway. Anyway,
oh, there was a Rich Campbell update that we didn't do as well.
Let me get this Rich Campbell update out of the way. Oh, I should
chill one more time. Guys, if you like the content, go ahead
follow on every platform, okay? On Twitch. It's twitch.tv/jsdk_x.
All right. Um, join, follow on Patreon, join the Discord. Okay.
discord.gg/jstk.
And if you really like the content, you can throw a couple bucks
my way. Make the stream go longer. All right. We've got 44 minutes
left. We are
Oh, what is this? This is
10 subs. 10 subs from two more hours on the stream. All right.
10 subs from two more hours. If we don't get it, if we don't
finish this here, or sorry, if we don't get more time here, we'll
probably go to a Patreon call earlier.
All right.
Yeah. What do we have coming up? We have the cutie Cinderella
stuff coming up. So, if you're interested in the cutie and Cinderella
stuff, we're probably looking for 10 subs to do two more
And if we don't get there, it's okay. We'll we'll do something
in the oil call after this. All right. So, go ahead. We're 10
subs away. You can sub on kick. You can sub on Twitch. You can
give Twitch primers. You can use either of the Streamlabs links.
Okay. either the TTS links to buy a TTS message through Streamlabs
or Kickbot exclamation point. Donate in the chat. We'll give
you those links. All right,
let's uh let's continue on with the content. Oh, there's also
a Patreon. Oh, there's some kicks actually from Marmadude.
Marad with the kicks. Himster earlier with the kicks. Thank you
guys so much. That's uh knocks it down what to nine subs. Nine
subs left to get two more hours on the stream.
All right, this seems to be like basically one of the final posts
that's going to come out. We'll get whatever stream Rich does
in a couple days, but this is going to be probably the last statement
from the Lexi person. Okay. Enclosed, please find a statement
from my attorney. To those of you posting about the resolution
of the disputes between Rich Campbell and Alexis Kurpan, please
be advised you have no idea what has happened. Only five people
know the full history. Myself, Mr. Miss Kerpan, Mr. Campbell,
and his two attorneys. None of us condone or approve of or encourage
or respect death threats, doxing, or her online harassment of
anyone. Attached here too are a notice of settlement and a dismissal
of the entire case with prejudice filed by Mr. Campbell's attorneys.
Oh, hold on.
>> Let's see here. Uh, Billy Joe Bush, Billy Bush, thank
you very much for the primer. Appreciate it. Appreciate you.
>> That's your two, our notice of settlement and a dismissal
of the entire case is with prejudice filed by Mr. Mr. Campbell's
attorneys and approved by the court. The dismissal includes both
Mr. Campbell's defamation action and Mr. Kon's assault action.
Just so it's clear, the public docket available online reflects
the following. 1215, 2023. Complaint filed by Mr. by Richard
William Campbell, plaintiff as to Alexis Marie Karpon, defendant.
April 23rd, 2024. Cross complaint filed by Alexis Marie Kpon.
Defendant as to Richard William Campbell. So Rich sued her. She
she counters sued Rich. Notice of settlement filed in 2025 by
Rich Campbell. Update request for dismissal filed by Rich Campbell.
So this this was the request for dismissal based on the settlement.
Uh T-OS 343. Thank you very much for the primer. Appreciate it.
Appreciate you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> And uh 10:21 2025 updated request for dismissal filed
by Oh, we got this one. You have you've seen Mrs. Kurpan statement
as approved of by Mr. Campbell. Mr. Campbell. Well, so I suspected
this was the case that they would have had statements that they'd
be issuing together, right? So she issued this statement. This
was something that had to be okayed. Like it just seems like
this was get this out of my life. When she says, "I wish him
well in his future endeavors." That's get this out of my life,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Leafy Bell. So when when people
are like, "Oh, this is proof." It's like a totally fake allegation.
Shut the up.
What is this? What is this? What is this? What is this? This
is a video of
>> Basically, what's going to happen is uh I'm going to
do that stream. I'm going to come back. I'm going to talk about
everything just one time. Then that's it. Then I'm going to talk
about everything that happened over the past 3 years. And then
I'm going to talk about everything that I'm planning to do in
the future. I'm going to talk about like my company, what I've
been doing there. Uh if you guys want to check it out, that would
be awesome. So, we're going to do that soon. >> Yeah. I
I guess I thought people maybe knew this, but it's good to point
out JB that dismiss with prejudice means that you you can't refile
this case. I think they both agreed to dismiss with prejudice
based on settlements.
Okay. In the meantime, I've greatly appreciated all of the support.
I really do over the past 3 years, everybody messaging me and
all of that stuff. I appreciate support. Sending death threats
to people, I just want to say one more time, I feel like I shouldn't
need to say this is not support. I don't want my name associated
with that in any
Please, no death threats, no weird. Get it under control. If
any of you are the people who have done that, um, the internet
is a dark, weird place.
What's the TLDDR on this situation? So, this guy's Rich Campbell.
He was a big streamer. He's a part of OTK, a huge streamer organization.
And then in I believe December of 2023
December of 2022 maybe he had a allegation against him. So let
me pull up his Twitter.
I'll pull up his Twitter. And it was an allegation of assault
or rape even. Okay. Yeah. December of 2022. An allegation of
rape against him by somebody. He was let go from his organization.
He said he'd make a statement and then he never made a statement.
He disappeared until about two weeks ago. Okay.
about two weeks ago he made a statement.
Any relation to the canned soup? No, I don't believe so.
I don't believe so. All right. So, he he made this statement.
He never made an actual statement. He just filed the lawsuit
about four or five months later and then they both had lawsuits
against each other and it eventually has come to nothing. Uh
but he was kind of cancelled. He was basically booted by a streamer
organization. He disappeared for multiple years. All right. All
right. So, going back to this was the clip of the rich stream.
There's more to come. Okay. Both parties have acted responsibly
and professionally throughout the this litigation. Those of you
who claim to be Mr. Campbell's fans disrespect him and the process
by engaging in death threats, doxing, or online harassment. Such
activities are being investigated for potential civil and criminal
prosecution and have been reported to the authorities. No further
statements will be issued on this matter by myself or Miss Karpon.
So yeah, it it just seems like basically she wants this done.
He probably wants this done and settled and for both of them
to move on. I'm guessing it came to they have a difference in
how they remember that night. There's no true way to like divine
what actually happened and neither of them are going to have
very much success in court beyond just wasting each other's money
and time. And so they're just going to stop. They're going to
say whatever, bury this. We we want to move on with our lives.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
So that's basically the I think going to be the end of the rich
stuff. We'll have one more statement from Rich where he talks
about everything and then after that
nothing else. Rich did what lawyers tell you to do. He kept his
mouth shut but yeah was a streaming ghost for years. Well it
wasn't I believe he was a streaming ghost or sorry I'm looking
at Leafy Bell's statement from before Arcandreel but I he was
a ghost. He probably could have just kept streaming. I think
he might have agreed to something with regards to OTK um and
just try to keep his like his his equity there. I think that's
to me it seems likely what happened.
Probably not the best choice in retrospect.
All right.
Okay. Why is Asmin getting scoot free from this? I don't know,
man. I don't know. Asold totally helped this guy get cancelled,
but apparently nobody cares. I know Rich won't care. Rich will
be totally happy to take Asminold's help in getting back into
streaming.
which I, you know, I get it. You want to get your career back.
So, Rich barely streamed and would only do sponsored streams
with a raid from Asmin. Also,
All right, fair enough. Okay, is this Msk trying to convince
me he was on
Wait, Msk was on steroids, though. He had like giga backne at
some point. This isn't the worst picture. There's a picture where
he's wearing like a um
there's a picture where he's wearing like a tank top like a red
tank top and
his shoulders are crazy. Yeah.
Yeah, it was the back knee in this and
everything. Okay. He was definitely on
All right. All right. All right. I think that's it for a lot
of the OTK stuff. What do we have left to go here? We have some
Teone stuff left to go. We have Sneo versus Myin. We've got Cutie
Do we go to the cutie Cinderella stuff?
Maybe we go to the cutie Cinderella stuff. We've got what? 20
minutes left on the stream. 30 minutes left on the stream. 35.
Okay, we'll see how it goes. We'll see if we can get there.
All right.
Oh, you know what I'll do though because we're getting we're
35 minutes away. Uh we'll do a supporter stream after this if
we don't hit the target. If you guys want to sign up for the
Patreon, here's the link. Probably just do similar content. I
might go through some of the stuff in the docket. Maybe we'll
do the Snego stuff. Probably if I'm going to do the supporter
stream, I'll maybe record it today so we can actually have it
uh go up on the Patreon after.
Who's worse, Misk or Doerty? Um, I don't know. I don't know anything
about Jack Dohy and anything I've seen of him is like just being
one of the worst human beings ever. Um, he's got like the whole
Only Fans management thing where he's like signing girls up when
they're 18. If that's all real, then probably him. But for Miz,
Miz I know is like a psycho on like a more personal level.
I think Dhert is probably worse. That that's how it seems to
me. But I again I don't know enough about Dhy to say for sure.
Okay. And I guess we'll probably end the Twitch stream about
now as well. So guys, we're going to head over to kick only for
the rest of the stream such as it is. All right. Head over to
We'll see you there in just a minute. I think we're going to
go on to the cutie Cinderella stuff. Bye-bye. Okay. Let's see
here. reviewing the cutie Cinderella
drama.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. All right. Welcome, guys. Welcome over to Kick. We're
checking this this Cutie Cinderella stuff out. All right. Let
me fire it up here.
Okay.
Cutie Cinderella collabed with Vanilla Mace, a pretty far-left
content creator with an even farther staunch leftist audience
in chat. Cutie Cinderella is giving takes that she refused to
hate her family or Lewig despite their views and takes or takes
on trans people or racism or homophobia and that she was still
communicating with these people and does it doesn't make her
bad or sorry still communicating with these people. Does make
her bad or a trans phobe. I think most of us are kind of familiar
with this. Apparently this is a Tik Tok that grabs the essence
of the situation. >> so this stream is happening. is this
vanilla mace person up here and cutie Cinderella and cutie is
going to talk about how hey I don't think it's appropriate to
like cut people off I think you know talking to people like they're
human beings right talking to people like they're human beings
is important
and yeah it's basically just that right
if hanging out with faze people triggered this oh we get into
that apparently all right Billy Joe Bush cuz I think the Faze
people are some of the people who make some of these homophobic
comments and Qie doesn't want to cut them off >> annoying
my shot right now why aren't >> They just be going. >> What
are they saying? Vanilla. >> Um that about the homophobic
jokes or like but then you just if you if you still hang out
with someone like that then you just support it. >> No.
So this is what I'm going to describe. Okay. And you guys can
believe what you believe. >> I know. Like I want like explain.
I want you like explain it better. >> I'm going to explain
it. You guys can believe what you want to believe. I understand.
But you're not allowed to coach me and say like that's not right.
That's not what you like just because I don't act that the same
way you act. You're not allowed to like coach me through that
because at the end of the day I am somebody that's like I'm an
ally. Like I am notic.
It doesn't matter who I talk to. Like the thing is like I come
I come I was raised in a very religious family. Unfortunately
there are people in my family that are racist. There are people
in my family that are bigoted. Um there are people in my family
that are homophobic. There's people in my family that are transphobic.
Like but I still love my family, right? And I still know that
there are like that members of my family have good qualities.
They have good qualities. And what's most important to get people
to love other people is to love them. Fighting hate with hate
will never get anything anywhere. If I were to say to someone
who's homophob >> so this is basically saying that you
can't bully people into a different position. It's obviously
true.
a lot of, you know, the lefty online space, like anything adjacent
to Tik Tok, any of the super far lefty spaces, they can't handle
takes on social issues like this. They literally can't handle
it whatsoever. So, I know I knew the second I heard any of this
stuff that this was going to blow back at Cutie Cinderella like
horribly. She's also got drama from like other things going on
recently, but we'll see. >> Go [__] yourself.
>> Yes, I told them what they deserve. However, they aren't
ever going to feel accepted. They're never going to learn how
to be accepting. >> Like, do you understand that if you
just write people off because they believe different things than
you, they're never going to be exposed to why it's good to be
around people that don't think like you, right?
>> So, my my step my my step um my stepbrother is trans
and my dad refuses to use the correct pronouns >> and does
Yeah. Right. Right. >> And he
>> he doesn't he doesn't understand that he um he doesn't
>> Shouldn't that be like a problem for your stepmom?
Right. Shouldn't that be like a major problem for your stepmom?
Like she's got a kid from a different relationship
and
and like your dad isn't respectful of that. That seems kind of
weird. I I feel I feel hyper I would feel so awkward in that
situation. >> Understand why it's so important, right?
And it drives me crazy and it drives my step brother crazy, of
course. But I've had to say to my dad, "Dad, you know, it's not
going to hurt you. It's not going to hurt you to say the correct
pronouns, but it does hurt him when you say the wrong ones."
>> Right. Right. >> And you know what the difference
is? is is I'm able to have this conversation with my dad because
I'm openminded and we love each other. My stepbrother just says
off and won't talk to my dad. So there's no progress being made.
Right. >> And so you can leave what you want. YOU GUYS
CAN YOU CAN SAY THAT. YOU can say to me, >> "Oh, I suddenly
Wait, I know how this turns on her." Right. Right there. That's
it right there. That she goes, "Hey, my stepbrother, he can't
even like stay calm and talk to my dad on this. He just he he's
like freaking out about Okay. I I listen, I don't necessarily
think that's what she means. I don't I actually think there's
a good chance that she doesn't mean how that sounds and she misspoke
cuz that would be kind of a wild thing to say.
Anyway, I I think so that's but I can I can see what how that
would set people off. And if you clipped it right there, oh boy,
that's rough. And I think that's what happens as we go through
this. From what I understand, she actually starts freaking out
about people clipping her and posting stuff, right? >> No,
you're supporting it. I'm not I'm not I'm not I don't support
that my father makes is transphobic at times. I don't support
that. I'm not I don't support it. Period. The end. But I still
love my dad and I'll go to coffee with him tomorrow. But I don't
support that. The world is not as black as white as everyone
thinks. Like you you guys you can't fight hate with hate. It
doesn't get you anywhere. It literally does not get you anywhere.
Like it's so important to like as someone who's very openminded
to be around close-minded people and show them that it's okay
to be openminded is actually one of the most important things
you can do like as a human. It really is. But I get it. You guys
can think what you think. I'm not going to change though. I'm
not going to I will never believe that if I'm kind to a hateful
person, that means I agree with them. I will never believe that.
No matter what you guys say, I won't believe it because at the
end of the day, if I'm around a racist person, I'm just not racist.
I'm not me. I'm not. They are. Yes. But how am I supposed to
help them ever by cutting them off? No.
There's like something to be said for this. This could be totally
correct, right? I do I do not disagree with this at this point.
K's chat seems supportive. I think most people's chats were supportive
and these people agree at this point in time. This doesn't switch
up until later on.
>> Like I I get it. You guys can think in black and white,
but that's not how it works over here. That's not how it works
for me. But >> sorry for the >> I feel like it's
No, don't be sorry. Don't be sorry. It's like again it's like
one of those things where it's like dang like it is like a thing
cuz again like there's definitely people in my family as well
that like are like pretty Trumpy and like uh my extended family
and um and I grew up around a lot of that too were um just hearing
remarks and and them saying things about just like you know people
that were not just white straight people and me kind of being
like what the like you know like quite literally what the and
like it's almost like a thing where it's like again this is like
my not really like my direct family so it's one of those things
where it's like okay I don't really see them like that anyway
so it's like what the [__] am I going to do like
blow up the dinner table right now like type it's like when I
feel like when when it comes to like real life like obviously
if it's somebody if I found out that like somebody who was like
a really [__] good friend of mine, whatever. Like
I mean that's the thing too. I'm like people that that are really
good friends of mine that I keep close to me, I already know
where their head's at. Like I feel like I already know where
their heads at when like it comes to like people that So like
that's not really something I worry about anyway. But I feel
like the with the most I feel like people in chat will be getting
so mad and I'm like y'all be acting like some of y'all family
members, brothers, sister, like other people that you have like
boyfriend
>> dude. Okay, my I have like a vague understanding of
the drama mostly from this point cuz I have watched I think a
good chunk of an Asin Gold video on this. Uh, it's so funny to
me that this Vanilla Maze person, doesn't she totally throw Cutie
under the bus despite her like standing up and supporting Cutie
right now in this take? How the [__] do you get away
with throwing her under the bus? What in the [__]
What is happening? How did she like how does she chuck Cutie
Cell under the bus? She's like, I know a lot of you have family
members that are racist and you're fine with them. And your boyfriend's
friends like will make like this is that these same people will
be in a room with their like loser ass boyfriend and then their
boyfriend's brothers or like friends or something will make a
gay joke or something and you'll sit there like you're you'll
sit there like that and then as soon as someone online isn't
like literally like standing like like like screaming like at
the roof of their like and then oh god they're the worst they're
the worst they're worst. >> I also think I think a lot
of people are misinterpreting a little bit about like what I'm
saying too. I'm not I don't judge my step brother for not talking
to my my
brother is allowed valid. >> He he is so allowed to be
p my dad and clearly like my dad is very hurtful when he use
his own pronouns. It makes me sad, right? It makes me very very
sad and that's totally fine that that's his
>> okay, so she clarifies and doesn't put the onus on her
brother to like be the person who has to make the first move.
That's good. >> I simply believe that I can coach people
into love. And I know that's [__] saying of me to
say, but I do think I can get my dad to not be transphobic eventually.
I believe >> that's the thing. And it happens. Like there
are so many stories of people out there being like like quite
literally being like, "Oh, I quite literally was >> That's
horrible. That's horrible for you, Space Hulk. I'm so sorry that
happened to you, buddy. >> I was XYZ, whatever transphobic.
And then they literally are like, and then I met someone who
either was one of these or something like that. And then like
you see these people and then I feel like people like I'll see
videos of [__] like that be like, "Wow, people can
change. That's so amazing." And then it's like but it took other
people around them to make that change. You know what I mean?
Like people like fighting people is like it just separates people
more. Like if you say, "You're so stupid. Why do you believe
in that?" compared to saying, "Huh, why do you believe in that?"
And genuinely having a conversation about it. Like >> I
like that's hard. I really understand. I understand that it's
hard and it's not for everybody. I really understand. But you
can't hold everyone to your same moral high ground and just assume
that because I am not doing what you would do. My my step brother
does not think I'm transphobic because I talked to my >> My
step brother doesn't think that. >> So why do people on
the internet think [laughter] that? You know what I'm >> Like
if I talk to so- and so who's transphobic, all of a sudden on
the internet, I am transphobic. Even if I would to say, "Oh,
I I've watched that streamer before." You watch a transphobic
streamer. >> There's like two different ways to look at
it. It's like one way it's like, do you think your brother would
feel better or worse if you said you weren't talking to your
dad until he could come to terms with your brother with with
like your brother not being your brother or vice versa? Maybe
your brother not being your sister or something. I don't know
which way the genders go there. Like your your brother would
clearly almost certainly feel better if you like harshly took
their side, right, and said made a moral stand of it.
But at the same time, I do think it's like quite normal to say,
well, if you just if you just like treat people like they're
monsters, you cut them off the second they do something wrong,
there's no chance for them to learn there, right? So, both I
understand both sides of like the the response and how she feels.
I lean more towards how she feels here. Like, you do need to
give people chances. You do need to calmly talk to them through
things. Uh, you won't be able to do it in just one or two sittings.
It like could be a process over time. You >> freak. You're
transphobic. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. You can't. You you guys
you simply cannot tell me what I am. >> You can't. And
you haven't watched me long enough if you think you can because
like I know what I am and I'm also very open to opinions, but
I'm not open to bullying of any kind. >> Even if that's
highing. I'm not open to that. It doesn't it's not helpful. >> Like
it's so it's never been helpful. >> Telling it's like telling
someone they suck because they're racist and and this is these
are so different terms. Like racist people telling someone they
suck because of skin color is obviously worse, but like all we're
doing is telling people they suck. Why are we like come on, let's
got to figure this >> Okay. Uh that is a very like dumb
take again. Listen, abstractly it's the same thing. It's just
getting mad at someone. Stop getting mad is like,
well, one of those is like quite wrong. I It It feels like an
equating of things where you shouldn't be doing it. And that's
not what she wants to do. And she's trying to like disc. It's
just It's like this weird
trying to have your cake and eat it too. >> And it literally
like And I'm the first person to like be like what the like so
to like sit back and like think about it from that different
perspective like quite literally is making me think too cuz I
am like the first person I feel like to get like what the [__]
and like just get up in arms over some [__] Granted,
if anything, >> oh, hold on. I think what I should say,
it's not going to take us too long to go through this stuff.
If we do hit the the sub goal, I think I'm going to do Sneak
Myron. So, if you guys are interested in Sneakyron, you could
be donating for that. Okay, >> that would just make that
person like people like me more. You know what I mean? Like they
almost like look for that sometimes. >> I have the privilege.
I have the privilege. I need to use it, right? I'm a straight
white woman. It'd be insane if I didn't use the privilege that
I have to help people navigate their
>> that's what I do. Like, that is this. Yes. You don't
have to do that if you are someone that's being viscerally attacked,
right? But me, who I am and where I stand, I do feel responsible
to try to help people. That's what I feel like I do. It's that's
that's my privilege.
I don't know. >> You know what? >> Well, that's our
yap for the day. Sorry. I'm like, well, guys, way to go. That
was good for me. [laughter] >> Katie, what do you think?
>> No, no, no. You guys are good. Like, I didn't want to
cut anybody off. Like, you guys had a lot of good things to say.
I was just sitting here like literally reading like the thoughts
in my chat. You guys You guys >> There's lot There's someone
in the chat right now. We just >> Also, I don't have this
sped up. I believe this is
Yeah, this is 1.0 speed. So, whoever did this, they clipped it.
They sped it up for us. Honestly, it's not hard to understand
what they're saying. So, >> saying like first being a Karen
like that, you know, stupid stuff like that. And it's like, okay,
guys, that's not it's just not helpful. It's not helpful for
anybody. It's It's never helpful.
>> Why is Dan allowed to astroturf R/ LSF while Stale 2000
sits in DG and watches him do it. I don't know. Don't super care.
That's Stale and Dan's thing. They can they can handle that however
they >> Like, it's not This is not helpful. Okay. But you
talked to them, so and they're horrible.
That's Did you not hear anything? thing I said
>> late night. >> Um, I'm trans and it really does
rub me the wrong way though, especially streamers will stop jokes.
Yeah, I think jokes suck. I've never said I like jokes. That's
the funny thing. I've never said that I like these jokes. I've
never said that. That's never come out of my mouth. Like, it's
just so silly.
That was silly.
Yeah, you're still downloading Pixel. >> You need to watch
the Cutie Lacy PR stream. I think that's why some people were
before this stream. Okay, maybe I do know there's some element
here of she's trying not to throw the Faze people under the bus,
too. And that's like a big thing. Like she basically has collabs
she does with FaZe Clan people. She doesn't want those to dry
up. So, she's not trying not to throw people under the bus for
like homophobic behavior either. >> Pixel, like that's
what everyone's saying, too. But, um, I downloaded in
>> Sorry. Was that too hot? Was I being too >> It's
a little warm. >> We definitely got a little warm here.
>> Sorry. I just I just feel like you got to build a bridge.
That's what I think. I think someone like me I'm not saying you
guys. No, I'm not safe for you to build a bridge. It might not
be safe for people in chat to build a bridge. >> Like I'm
trying to get people to be more openminded. That's that's what
I would like to do. >> I would like people not to be racist.
I'd like people not to be transphobic. I'd like people not to
be homophobic. I'm like I would like a lot of things. Um and
I I simply try by loving people. And I know that's naive sometimes,
but >> Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Right.
>> Right. Your tape, you know. >> No, I I'm getting
a little I'm emo only right now. >> Oh boy. >> Um
but they they my email only. But it's it's a little mixed reviews.
people are understanding these people are not. But that's qu
literally like anything like anyone can kind of just like this
is a conversation that you could you could you could go back
and forth all day about you know what I mean. It's just one of
those things. Um >> you're still allowing them to act racist.
I'm not when they're act [laughter] you guys don't get it. If
someone is actively around me no they're not doing those things.
And that's why it's good to be around people that are loving
and able to say hey that makes me uncomfortable. That makes me
uncomfortable. I'm talking about people in my life right? Like
>> I'm not talking about you guys think everyone on the
internet is friends. Like we're not. >> Yeah. Also that
too. I feel like a lot of people um a lot of people uh think
that just cuz like you've like met one person or something that
it's like oh my god she's like on my girlfriend now I don't know
that [__] man. Oh hell no [__] like random
[__] like that.
>> Yeah. I don't know man.
>> Oh well. >> Hey let's go let's go ghost hunting
if you want or >> let's go freaking ghost hunting chat.
Clean all the chats. Sorry. We know it's a very
>> it's a it's a very hateful world right
>> Yeah. It's hard not to get rage baited these days too.
>> I know. And I feel like this is going to get clipped.
>> Oh I'm looking. Apparently, there's new docs in the
Pixie case that got filed. I'm trying to look into that on the
side here while we're watching this. >> I know that's what
I'm nervous about. People are like, "No, you crazy. >> Should
we bl
just unlist the VOD?" I guess uh Katie can't. She has the show.
>> I stopped it and researching. >> Oh, did you?
>> Yeah, I can listen. >> You could you could just
cut this part cuz I just don't like I'm not I'm not in the mental
head space to be dealing with right now. I'm quite lit. >> I'm
going to delete my >> Okay, perfect. >> I'm just
going to delete it cuz it's not like we did anything important
today either. Let's be honest. I got you. >> We didn't
even make We couldn't even make a YouTube video. >> Guys,
we can go off email only right
>> I'm going to delete >> this looks better.
>> The update the fast for looks good. >> Oh, does
it? Okay, you might want to delete clips, too, just so you know.
>> Okay, I think my mod is the only one that can make clips.
I think that you deleted your
>> Cutie. Cutie's got it. Guys, listen. We're just going
to DMCA everyone. All
No, no, no. I believe I believe she's getting ready to DMCA anybody
who does this as well. >> Guys, we can go off only right
now,
>> Words. Okay, >> I'm going to delete. >> This
looks better. >> What? the update. The fast is good. >> Oh,
does it? Okay. You might want to delete clips, too, just so you
know. >> Okay. I think my mod is the only one that can
make clips. I think that you deleted your bod. >> It doesn't
post automatically. >> Um, you can still pull it. >> Uh,
it doesn't post automatically. Even if you delete it, it's still
grabbed. I This is so silly. This is like Cutie
Cutie brought this on herself. This is the worst possible way
to handle the situation. Why don't you just DM people, cutie,
why would you do this? Why the [__] would you go
Oh, you need to take your VA down. Yeah, guys. Uh, people are
making a big deal out of this. Delete all the evidence. Delete
all the evidence. Get it all off the internet. Delete it now.
Delete it now. Did you delete it yet? Did you delete it yet?
I've been really worried about this going public anywhere. Uh,
listen. >> Somebody in my chat asked me not to delete the
vod if that's okay with you >> you could edit it. >> No,
I'm just kidding. Now, I'll delete [laughter] the What I got
to delete like the clips, too. >> You just you just Yeah.
Okay. >> Just go to video producer.
>> No, no, no. I know how to delete clips. I do. I'm asking
You go to channel. >> Or you go to creator dashboard and
then you go to content and then video producer and then you click
the three dots and then you just push delete.
>> Cut. Don't delete. You'll lose context. I already deleted
it. It's fine. Listen, if people on the internet want to believe
what they want to believe, they can. Like I can't change what
people think, you know?
>> I don't think deleting the good queen. Uh, it's to protect
ourselves. Listen, there's been too many hate threads in the
past two days. I don't care how it looks. I want I care how my
friends feel. So, shut the [__] up about that one.
Thanks. >> I just need a literally I just need >> I
just can't do it anymore. Vanilla and >> I know it's it's
crazy on the internet actually. Like >> I think it's it's
kind of wild to me to be like uh delete all the clips, delete
all the VODs as somebody who this is your job. Like I don't you
kind of have to accept that you might say something stupid and
you get like kind of screwed over by some clip. Isn't that a
part of the job?
>> Okay. My bod's deleted. Is your bod >> Mine is.
>> I think so. >> You got it. >> I don't have
the brain power to play the freaking ghost game anymore. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> No, don't be sorry. Did I ruin the >> No,
no, no, no. >> Yeah, I'm only going to stay on for one
anyways. I feel like it doesn't make sense anyways. Like, now
all the chats are probably distracted, too. Which >> Okay,
sorry. That's my fault. I think your guys' chats aren't used
to my takes and I said don't >> No, don't freaking worry
about it. Don't worry about it. >> Don't worry about it
at all.
La. I know. I'm seeing some good comments. I'm seeing some very
good comments. So, >> it's okay. Even if you're mad, it's
okay. I understand that makes people >> Yes. And she understands.
She understands that. >> Yeah. Literally everybody I'm
seeing in this chat is like is it must be this vanilla maze person's
chat, right? Cuz everybody I'm seeing in this person's chat is
just like oh like oh sorry that sucks cutie. Let's go sub only.
Let's like help cutie out. Everybody in this chat is like help
is trying to be supportive of cutie. >> And a lot of weird
is going on in the world and everything lately. It's just it's
overwhelming sometimes, you know? It's just overwhelming >> and
sometimes we just need a little
Dude, I want to I kind of want to see this person's chat. The
vanilla mace person's chat just because
like did cutie see like two comments. She just freaked out.
Oh, that's weird. Okay, that's the whole thing there. That's
the first VOD. All right, so
Cutie starts getting hate and finds out people are uploading
clips to the stream and says she will cease and desist
Twitter accounts uploading the clips. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Why did she say this? Why? What is she >> Uh, someone said
that there's someone uploading my VOD onto Twitter. Is that what
you said? If you could send my mod.
>> oh god, she's got the Elinity Cadence right here. Copy
strike this guy. Copyright this strike guy. Copy strike this
guy right now. Copy strike him. >> The username. I will
send them a cease and desist or you can give a heads up >> doing
that like
>> h that like totally sugary sweet
way of speaking as you're like about to try to DMCA somebody
very very bad very >> or if they're watching this right
now I will sue you quite literally
okay this doesn't make any sense pensive goat does it wait what
what is her copyrighted material there what material does she
hold the copyright for was she singing like her own unique composition
or was she doing like other people's music?
If she's doing her own unique composition then okay maybe she
decided to sing because the VOD was already being deleted
her own music apparently.
>> I'm not doing that. >> So if you could link that
Twitter account to
my uh
that's a money waste. It's not actually. It's like
>> we'll see. We can look more into this. Hold on.
>> I'm happy to spend 500 bucks to prove a point. Uh, when
I have a VOD unlisted and I choose not to upload it to make money
for myself, you're not allowed to take advantage of the content
that I am creating that you are doing nothing for. >> Depends
on how much. Honestly,
she's kind of honestly she's kind of right in that if people
were uploading the whole VOD, that would probably be a problem,
right? She would have the right to DMCA people asking or sorry,
uploading her whole VOD. If people are uploading clips that that
can't be DMCA. She does say VOD here though >> without
my permission. There's lots of people that do it with my permission,
but again,
let me know the second you have that Twitter account.
>> Oh, Black Ice. I see I see this could be >> Send
it over to my lawyer right now.
>> Okay. All right. So, we got this one. Now, apparently
there's a bunch of controversy around
whether or not she was protecting music or not. So, this is what
I got sent was, "Oh, now she's like coping about this, right?
So, let's let's look into it a little bit. What Cutie said in
the stream was horrible, and she should slash is going to hold
herself accountable, but what helps no one is lying about the
situation, misconstruing the clips. Her cease and desist was
in reference to her songs, not towards her statements from earlier.
Yes, it's fine to post it. When I was talking about DMCing VOD
uploaders, it was because I sang three of my unreleased songs.
I always delete my singing videos. I didn't even know at this
point how poorly I worded things. Of course, you can upload clip
my clips. Anyone saying I'm suing anyone over uploading clips
is blatantly lying. I only talked about Season Desist in regards
to my music because I have worked so hard on it. I didn't want
to get it leaked. I didn't realize that there would be that it
would be misconstrued so much.
Okay, hold on. Let's just go take a look,
right? Let's go. Let's go take a >> I don't care if they're
posting drama, but if they're posting my
singing, that's up. I don't care. I don't. >> Okay, that's
interesting. I don't care if they're posting drama, but they're
posting my singing. That's up. When was that? Was that after
somebody had posted about her deleting the VOD?
Let's go. Let's go figure it out. Hold on. We got some cutie
Cinderella here over on There we go. Here we go. When was this?
This would have been gaming with Vanilla and Katie. It's this
one. >> Check on Swift and P and I'll be right >> So,
she was doing this.
Hold on. We're listening. >> Oh, I don't care if they're
posting like drama. Um,
>> I don't care if they're posting drama, but if they're
posting my
singing, that's up. I don't give a [__] if they think
I'm an I don't care.
>> This is her at is this the I can't tell if this is the
end of her stream. Give me a second. I need to see which order
this goes in.
Yeah, this would be the end of her stream. Oh my god. >> But
the weird thing to me is she hadn't even been singing at this
point, right?
So like or maybe she sang at the very start of the stream. This
seems to be like the very end of the stream and she just changed
her title to singing songs. Not good. Just like to sing as a
hobby. No need to be mean. So that's the title of this part of
the VOD. And she'd just gone to it. Oh no. No. Sorry. She had
been singing here. I lied. I lied. I lied. I clicked I clicked
through first. >> Hello Ray. Sorry. I'm going to end spent
an hour and a half singing. um
>> Now, here's the question. When did she actually say
the part
about deleting the
>> Is this right here? >> Said that there's someone
uploading my VOD onto Twitter. Is that >> Let's see. >> One
second.
>> People areable.
Like genuinely
>> people are genuinely insufferable. I feel like this
is a weird thing to talk about. Rain, you seem kind of demented
for bringing it up. >> Cassidy, you can type a user. >> Okay,
so this is already after the Twitter thing had been brought up.
>> Singing stream. Hope you're not too late. I'll do one
more song and then I'll be done.
Reflections on glasses. It's okay. Blocked by someone else. >> Sorry,
it's going to be a little slow here as we look around through
this. We're poking. We're poking around.
>> Trying to figure out where she says stuff, but she doesn't
talk. >> Is awesome is for the record, I don't even do
my own blocks. All these people get so
defensive when they get blocked by me and they're literally blocked
by someone else. Ignore them. Okay, I'm just seeing if someone
is uploading my VOD. I am >> Okay, never mind. I can't
I can't actually spend the time to go and look through and figure
out the truth of this. I'll just leave it ambiguous. I can look
into it after. Okay, we're going to keep looking cuz I want to
watch the vanilla mace stream. All right, that's actually where
the drama is. I don't really care if Cutie was covering this
up or not to be honest with you. Doesn't super matter.
go over to the van vanilla mace stream over here. So, Vanilla
Mace then has to has to do a stream right in the line of apologizing
but not outright on cutie Cinderella because she supported Cutie
in the moment, but she also knows her chat hates cutie right
now because of the things that Cutie had said. So, she needs
to like somehow find the line. She needs to ride the line to
make sure she doesn't [__] on Cutie too hard, but
that she does disavow at the same time. >> How are you
guys? How's everyone? Oh, someone with a 19 sedate me with a
19month sub or resub. Thank you so much. Thank you so much.
Um,
hi everyone.
So, this is a little bit of a serious
stream as I drink and eat my soup. I got a Thai soup. I've never
had it before. It's some sort of lemongrass coconut cream soup.
It's very yummy.
[snorts] >> Different from anything I've ever tasted before.
I forgot what it was called, but it's pretty good.
Um, so don't mind me if I'm eating as I'm talking.
Um, but [clears throat] yeah, we have some stuff that we need
to talk about. Also, I don't The lighting kind of sucks. My I
have a migraine, so I'm don't have my big light on, so bear with
me. Um,
no, you guys are not in trouble. I keep seeing everyone's like
I'm scared
like I'm gonna freaking get it. So, I'm going to spank you. I'm
not gonna spank you, okay? You [clears throat] This is not a
you guys, okay, thing. I [snorts] obviously, you know, this is
just about everything that's been going on. Um, >> this
person looks like I No, never mind. >> Just this month
as a whole and um
>> with stream I was going to comment. I'm not going to
comment. >> For those of you who don't know, actually I'm
sure I don't know who the doesn't know at this point. >> Somebody
from Greece. No, that's not who I'm thinking. >> Over Tik
Tok and everything and um it's been living in my brain rentree
ever since it happened. Um [snorts]
uh there was a stream that you know me me cutie and Katie we
>> this is like okay not not in terms of the voice but
in terms of the appearance appearance this is like Alyssa Mercante's
cousin that was born in Northern England. Okay that's that's
what I pick up here like Alyssa Mercante's blood relative that
is also mixed with northern English and this is what has been
produced. >> Um we were playing some games and um
We somehow got on the topic of just parasocial people because
because Katie was talking about how her chat at this time of
night always tells her, "Oh, you need to go to bed. You need
to go to bed. You look so tired. You look so tired." And then
the the conversation kind of just like spun into something that
it shouldn't have ever
went to in the first place. It was just not a conversation that
needed to happen on stream. And um [laughter] it was very like
it was just like an awkward uncomfortable thing for everybody
involved. Um >> you like reassured her that it wasn't awkward
or uncomfortable. You're like, "No, no, no. It's totally fine.
We should have this conversation." Wasn't she like, "No, no,
no. We're totally good to have this conversation. This isn't
weird."
>> And
yeah, so that's basically like what happened. And um [snorts]
if first and foremost I would like to say that
the idea of deleting the VOD was my idea. Okay? And if you watch
the full thing back, you will literally
hear me say, "Can we just [__] delete this?" cuz
I am not in the mental space right now
to deal with
just what I already know is going to come from this because I
already knew
this was going to be >> to be a whole thing. >> That's
like really interesting because that kind of gets cutie off the
hook for the stri ending if that's the case. If cutie like picked
up that she wanted it deleted and she was just trying to support
it's still dumb but it gets cutie a little bit off the hook for
stri ending it so badly.
So, that was my idea. So, I'm just going to let that be known
once and for all. >> Um,
also after the fact, too, if you were here, >> I think
we're what are we? We're nine subs from two more hours in the
stream, guys. 2 minutes 50 seconds left.
>> we'll finish this story. >> If you were here for
the live, uh, after that conversation was had and we all like,
you know, went our separate ways,
started crying. I started crying. And it was not about necessarily
what had happened, but Oh, a rogue eyelash. Thank you. It was
not about what had happened, but it was
more so just like everything as a whole. And I
was just getting emotional.
Um because there's had been just been there's been a lot going
on this month. There's just been a lot going on this month. And
um
>> you know, there were some things that were said that
I did not necessarily
>> like what >> agree with or think that >> um
could have been said better probably. >> I don't think
any of us can understand the pressure you're under right now.
>> cutie needs to address this. The thing is, I know
where Cutie's heart is and I know that she tries to have everybody
in the community come together
and um you know there's we have had conversations in private
about this and that's not something that you guys need to like
know about, but like you know I'm not going to go into detail
on that. And
I just don't
want anyone to think that
I
there's all I'm going to say is that there it's like I'm trying
to be like freaking PR right now.
There are clips of me
giving other people advice, literally saying, "You are who you
hang out with." And I've given people advice. People have been
like, "Hey, my my boyfriend this XYZ, >> bro, these people
suck." Um,
you know, >> I did she write this down? Is she reading
from a script? >> Like with this guy
or whatever. >> Oh, the these people will script their
social interactions and then when they're addressing controversy,
they won't write anything down. It should be the opposite. Have
normal human being social interactions that aren't scripted and
aren't like running under some set of rules. And then when there's
some controversy, write a script so I don't have to listen to
you mumble your way through your feelings and repeat the same
[__] 80 times and never get anywhere. It's unbearable.
>> And I have literally
said,
"Hey, you are who you hang out with."
And
so for that take of,
you know, it's you are not who you associate with was not necessarily
something that I agreed with. And I don't want it to seem like
I'm backpedaling on something because I have quite literally
said that in the past that I have stood on that and said I personally
think if you hang out with somebody
who is
you know XYZ
that what does that have to say about your character kind of
a thing.
Although I do think the clips were taken out of context a little
bit. I do think the the clips were taken out of context.
Um
and and now people are and I and of >> Oh, hold on. It's
it's funny how she doesn't understand that you are who you hang
out with goes both ways. They could be a negative influence,
but you can be the positive, but you can be a positive one. Yeah,
sure. Sure, sure. That you are who you hang out with. That doesn't
mean you only hang out like either. It also implies that unless
you're the ex have the exact same beliefs as anybody you hang
out with, somebody's a bad person there, right?
But yeah, like it's it's literally she's like, "Yeah, you are
who you hang out with. That's why I'm not going to leave my dad
to be like a terrible person forever on his own." Yeah, exactly.
>> People are saying, "Oh, you were nodding your head and
stuff and everything."
What when you It's It's hard when you're put in that position
because one, with all of our chats combined, there are over 10,000
people watching.
And quite literally when anyone is talking to me I I go like
this. When anyone is talking to me about anything that's just
like I'm just like uh-huh uhhuh uh-huh. Like that's just some
that's just a conversational thing
that happens with anyone that I talk to.
So
that's just that. And I think if you watch the full thing, you
could obviously feel the tension. You could feel that
it was a little awkward for everyone.
Um, and
it it's more of a thing where I know that I, as a white woman,
have
the privilege of being
able to be in some spaces and be
What is the race about? I don't
This is just all This is all like making me like angry and I
don't know where to go with it. Like I I'm just like angry the
whole time I listen. I It's just like what what is the what is
going on here? What is the purpose of any of this? Um the shape
shifters are the worst. The day walkers
I don't have to worry for my safety and that I don't have to
worry for
you know what I mean? So >> like do these people even try
anymore? They just like have a set of talking points they were
given like 3 years ago. They don't understand. They don't try.
They put no effort in. She like, "Yeah, I think like people were
like worried about safety or something, right? Like I, you know,
I'm white. I know I don't have to worry about anything. I know
I get everything for free because I'm white. This is what you
guys want to hear, right? White people get everything for free
all the time and like other everybody else has to like totally
fear for their lives all the time. That's how it goes." Right.
Right. >> I could never sit here
>> and try to tell people like marginalized people how
they should feel about comments like that. Um, and I Okay, I
don't Everyone is saying saying, "Are you guys listening to what
I'm saying right now?" Like, this chat is confusing the [__]
out of me.
Are y'all listening to what I'm saying? Like, genuinely,
are you listening with the with the sound on or no? Like, what?
[snorts] I am telling y'all that I
why people
are upset about that. I >> on principle I'm going to keep
going with this cuz I said I would do it and I I gringo grabbed
me a bunch of links. But holy do I ever want to blow my brains
out listening to this person speak. Like I actually I am definitely
like
about to smash my head into my desk.
But I'm telling you that I know and understand
why
>> that is a take that people are upset about. Okay? Because
>> as somebody who has a as a white person who recognizes
>> it's like mad libs. It's like mad libs the whole time
>> that I have white privilege
that they're >> Dude, what the is even happening? Never
mind. This is going into being funny >> There are certain
people that can be in rooms
and and have comments like that be made and it
it would affect them
in ways that could affect them for the rest of their life because
they are it is a personal attack on them.
Do you get what Cinderella is saying? I don't want to cut off
my dad because I don't think that cutting him off and leaving
him to stew in his bigotry is a good way to operate. And I understand
as a white woman with somebody with white as somebody with white
privilege that there are people who will be hurt who will be
scarred for a lifetime by that
I feel like she is doing Mad Libs. She's like doing the the marov
chain right of like the next best word to say and she's not thinking
about what she's saying at all. She like can't connect the concepts
of like what she's saying to what
>> What I'm saying? >> She's infantilizing minority
groups and and different identity groups, but it's like not related
to this conversation. It's like just trans people. And she keeps
bringing up her race, right? marginalized groups of people cannot
be in rooms where people are making these kinds of jokes and
XYZ and whatever and have it be something that can be excused
or written off.
>> Who made a joke? Where's the joke >> because it's
something that could affect them for the rest of their lives
and it's stuff that they have to deal with constantly. I mean,
if they have to deal with it constantly, it seems like if they
are going to be scarred for a lifetime every time something happens
that they deal with constantly, then aren't they like totally?
Doesn't don't you need like some kind of paradigm shift there?
This happens so often. These people are scarred for life all
the time. It's like, oh well, it seems like probably that's like
a major problem. Like you can't live that way now. And also too
as a queer woman as well [laughter] obviously another it's just
one of those things that is just it is just was just
uncomfy. It was just uncom [laughter] for everyone and I am just
letting you know that as somebody who you know as a friend and
as somebody who was like hey
>> I was kind of the one who was like hey can you elaborate
on that? I was the one who who in a sense dragged it out because
I wanted to I I was like almost a little confused. I wanted to
hear more >> and so I was the one that was like, "Hey,
my chat is like, you know, I wanted to hear more."
Yes. You totally baited her into doing this. Yes. You convinced
her that it was okay to continue along with like the way she
was feeling about this and continue to describe how she felt
about it, right? Yeah. 100%. And
I just don't think [laughter] it that was obviously not
something that
helped anything.
Um,
>> I mean, she just restated the same position again. >> Sorry,
I'm reading. >> Actually, she clarified and made it like
>> And yeah, so how did this even start the
[snorts] Okay. Why did it have to be so public? That's another
thing that I'm wondering as well. See, that's the thing. I don't
know how it even like went down that road or why it went down
that road. And I don't think it should have because I just don't
think it's a it was it was just not a conversation for stream
simply at the end of the day.
>> Yeah, it was.
What do you mean it wasn't It's like clearly something she cares
about. You're people who talk about these social issues. Why
is it not a conversation for stream? >> It was just not
a conversation for stream. And one thing I'm going to Okay, see
that >> she did indeed Kirsty. >> And again, I don't
want to like have to bring up receipts and to make it seem
you know, but I have I have quite literally had instances in
the past where I have had very good friends that have ended up
making comments that were like very like just blatantly
racist, like just straight up racism. Like I had a friend a few
years ago who was a very good friend of mine who during the height
of the BLM protests and the beginning of COVID um had made a
comment
it's just something and was like, "Oh, but look at look at like
look at all these black people looting Target." And I literally
whipped my head around and I was like,
what?
Who are the people looting target?" That [laughter] is just straight
up like that is just insanity. Like that right there like that's
just racism. And then then >> I mean if they didn't know
if they saw Target was getting looted and they're like oh black
people must be looting target then that's racist. If he was looking
at like all black people looting a target then that wouldn't
really be racist be a descriptive fact, right? I I don't know.
There could be some world where that's not a racist statement.
>> Down a whole long line of of me and her not becoming
friends any being friends anymore. And that was a whole another
thing because that was just straight up somebody just being racist
like in front of a >> dude tell me tell me I know low tier
god streaming a lot recently. Tell me we've got low tier god
reacting to any of this. I feel like this part specifically I
want to see low tier god's reaction to >> My face.
So, and I I
like to pride myself on like
I have turned down
bags because people that I do not agree with their views and
things that they stand for would be in that same room. Like I
don't do
just for the money. I don't do just for
>> Hold on. Don't >> I don't do things just for the
money.
Uh, Tyson Tyson Inwood or Tyson Lynwood donated $50. Oh my gosh,
she doesn't do things just for money. >> Tyson Lynwood
donated $50. Hey, sorry to >> Trust me, guys. We're going
to we're going to donate this all to the the nearest gender queer
organization we can >> Vanilla, but can we please get the
comments turned off mods? There are a lot of people strictly
to >> Thank you so much, Tyson. my mods know what they're
doing and people that's why I'm letting people >> I'm just
waiting for the uh I'm waiting for the don so the message to
come where somebody's like you're accepting donations during
this are you are you are you really accepting donations for >> I'm
letting people speak I'm letting people um say what they have
to say as long as it's not just like straight up [__]
hate and not any sort of like constructive criticism I'm letting
people say what they have to say right now um
but at the end of the day I am somebody who believes that
essentially you are who you associate with at the end of the
day.
That being said, in this space, there obviously are things and
events where you're you're you're going to be in the same room
as people that you don't always necessarily agree with all the
time. So,
that's just a given. Okay.
But
me personally, I would never go out of my way to collab or to
do something with somebody oneon-one that I do not agree with
their morals.
>> So true. >> What a queen. So amazing. So brave.
and I understand
that a huge part of my community is marginalized people and most
of the people in my life are marginalized people. So, as somebody
who has that privilege,
simply all I can do is sit back and listen. That's simply all
I can do is sit back. >> I apologize, guys. That's on me.
I did not 1.5x this from the start. Okay? that is on me that
I let her yap at like 1x speed for so long >> and listen
and listen to what people are saying and obviously in the moment
it was just uncomfortable and everything and whatever
but hold on
and I'm not throwing anybody under the bus. I'm liter I am not
throwing her under the bus. See that's the thing too is we had
a a we >> No, you're totally throwing her under the bus.
had a conversation and I was like legit like cutie as your friend
and she also is agreeing with me and saying you know what obviously
the way that it came out was wrong the tone of everything was
wrong like everything was wrong like the way that I said everything
so and she plans on saying something and that whenever she decides
to do that that's on her but I'm speaking for me right now you're
legit just talking about your views on it exactly because that's
what what else would I be talking Yes
because I can only speak for me >> wait hold on you you
mean you could just say words and speak for you and not could
be concerned or care about the consequences for anybody else.
Oh, cool. Cutie's just got a note. None of these people can be
mad at her. Apparently, that's totally fine when she does it.
She can just speak. Oh, I'm just speaking for me. I'm not speaking
for Nobody should feel bad about the Okay, so just say cutie
was doing that. Boom. Done. Easy. So, with that being said, I
am not going to be doing any collabs with anyone for a very long
time. I just think Twitch is just in a very weird place right
now. I'm not going to be doing collabs with with with anyone
for a while. Um, and I just kind of want to go back to just me
and my chat and with the exception of Minecraft with Julian.
Yes, with the exception of Minecraft with Julian because that's
>> seems like a great solution. >> The little series
that me and Julian do. But I just >> I'm never going to
deal with this problem festering in my community. I'm just going
to let it I'm just going to let it fester. Let it boil over.
Okay, I'm just going to not talk to anybody while this continues
to get worse. >> A breather. I just I just need to just
kind of >> have everything just be me and my chat and just
that's it. And as far as I'm talking about for content, you know
what I mean? For like you're not going to see Yes, it doesn't
m it doesn't matter who and it's not and it's not like it's nothing
against anyone. It's just simply I want to just go back to the
[__] that I used to do back when I first started
streaming. That's it. That's all.
That's simply all. Um and I'm hold on. I'm just reading because
I like to hear what you guys have to say. As a black woman, you
are three white people sitting and coming from a space where
you can speak this way. You were put in an uncomfortable situation
in a very public setting and that is unfortunate. but not taking
a stance on it and saying no collabs with anyone is a way of
being complicit and not speaking out on how it was uncomfortable
for other identities. See, I feel like did did were you guys
listening for the beginning of the stream? I was quite literally
saying how it it is very uncomfortable for other people and it
was very uncomfortable for other people in marginalized communities,
which is why I'm saying that I am recognizing that there are
people that cannot be sat in >> I think this is why marginalized
communities stay marginalized sometimes. Okay, if you can't handle
people like giving their opinions in a way that isn't meant to
be destructive, in a way that's meant to be engaged with and
they they're willing to admit they could be wrong on things,
if that hurts you too much to engage with at all, then maybe
you're going to stay marginalized for like a long time. >> Rooms
with people who would have who would make jokes of that nature
and have it not be a personal attack on >> That is is literally
what I'm trying to
That's that's literally what I'm trying to say
is that I I I know that and that's why the whole thing upset
me and that's why we are where where we at. That's why we are
where we are at right now. Okay? Because
you listen to your thoughts on because there are plenty of marginalized
people that cannot
that that stuff like that is not a joke is what I'm trying to
say is that that is stuff like that is not a joke at the end
of the day.
so yeah.
Okay. Um, guys, I think what we're going to do here is we're
going to
we're going to finish this part of the video and we'll cut this
segment in half. Finish it tomorrow. If you guys do, I I pinned
the Patreon link in the kick chat. We'll probably go to a supporter
stream. I think maybe we'll do the Tactical Templar stuff. I'll
see if it's like if I can get it to go like if I can get it.
I know Substance posted all the links. We can go do the T tactical
Templar stuff. Take a look in the in the supporter stream. Okay.
And yeah, I'm interested in seeing it. So yeah, we can go go
through a lot of it. Ble, let's watch the far TV show. Ah, >> I'm
telling you, I am like literally telling you right now that I
did not agree with that. Okay, I'm telling you right now that
>> How much is the link's right there, >> I did not
agree with that. But I'm not going to come on here and start
dogging and hating on people like that. That's just not also
a way to go about it either. But I'm telling you that I did not
agree with the things most of the things that were said. I do
think that some of the stuff that she said came out wrong and
I do think that she may not see it in the way that you know she
she may I think that she probably sees it differently now obviously
and that was kind of the conversation that we were >> is
that hey sometimes you just need to listen to what people are
saying and listen to to the feedback that people are giving you.
>> It's five bucks. It's five bucks for the supporter stream
>> simply. Well, Frank, here's the thing, okay? I usually
take the donos to add time to the stream. If there's a time where
we're listen, it's coming up on the holiday season, people feeling
a little light in the wallet, we can't make the donations to
make the stream go longer, then we'll go to the Patreon stuff.
It's not my fault that the stream was incredible content, just
wall to-all for 8 hours every day for months on end. That's not
my fault. Well, it maybe is my fault, but now we have now we
might have some time to do some Patreon stuff.
so yeah, I'm just reading again. >> Yeah, KT did also apologize.
>> It was something that just didn't need to be talked
about. It it just it again it was my idea to delete the FODs.
Not in and it was not in the sense where I don't want people
to know like that that this was like something that was talked
about or not me in a way that was like trying to like save her.
It was quite literally I am not in the headsp space to just deal
with what I already knew was going to come from that. Like I
already knew I was like oh brother like I already know how this
is going to go and and that's simply how it went. So, that's
the one thing that I'm gonna say is that that was my idea to
delete the [__] tree. >> Um, we could do we
could do some of the doc stuff. I think it's like not super interesting.
I think it's basically Pixie saying, "Hey, the the protective
order governing public commentary hasn't been like hasn't done
anything like there's no movement on it." I think it's like not
super there's not a ton. >> No, I'm not saying it's all
my fault. Are y'all like Oh my god. Y'all literally like what?
>> There is like lots of content. >> I say one thing
and then y'all say a whole another thing. Like please just listen
to what I'm saying. Just listen to what I'm saying. >> Why
don't they understand? Do I have to do anything in Discord to
verify? Uh, Chappie, there's like a guide on the Patreon for
linking your your Patreon subscription to the Discord. I think
sometimes you have to leave and rejoin. Like, it'll get you to
leave and rejoin.
But yeah, then it's uh it's Yeah, if you get the supporters thing,
you could just integrate through Patreon and it'll tell you exactly
how to do it. And yeah, it should be all good, I think. >> I'm
just reading. I'm reading right now. Just reading. Just reading.
Yeah, at the end of the day, I just don't want to be crucified
for things that I didn't say, basically is is also what I'm trying
to say. Um,
yeah. So, can we all can we all agree on >> So, she surely
she's got to be done soon. Please >> love you, mama. What
happened to you are who you associate with. That's quite literally
what I started off the stream with. I said I am someone who has
always stood by that and has always said that. I have always
said that. Okay. I have always said you are who you associate
with. Okay? So, I am standing on that is what I'm telling you
right now.
Are we all on the same page?
Are we all on the same page yet? >> Guys, can't you just
all agree that she didn't do anything wrong? Is that really that
difficult to just agree that she did nothing wrong at all? Like,
absolutely nothing.
Absolutely nothing that she could have possibly done wrong. Come
on, man. >> Is it opposite [laughter] day or God? See,
it's it's it's like so hard to come on here and I can disagree
with her without having to publicly bash her, okay? is what it
okay but all I'm going to say is I'm not doing any collabs with
>> anyone
hi vanilla girl first time dono here sorry for >> interrupting
huge >> to myself and many others please remember that
I can't imagine >> I can't imagine navigating situations
publicly like this don't forget to give yourself grace love you
hand and me with a $50 dono thank you so much I really appreciate
that hand thank you thank you thank you and I eat red 40 with
the five gifted thank you so much I feel like people want like
y'all just want the drama at this point some people just want
the drama and they just want the clips and this I'm I'm not going
to come on here and just be like >> how many viewers does
this person at this VOD has 270,000 views and her chat is flying
like I see [__] XQC's chat fly. She got to get a
viewers. She got to be 5K plus, right? Hold on. Uh what would
it be? A Selnome
and then Vanilla
Vanilla Mace. Let's take a look. She gets a viewers or she was.
Okay, so she's normally averaging like 5,000. She was at like
10 11,000 average for this stream. Pick peak 16,000.
So, her chat was flying. >> Like, that's just not something
that I would ever do. Like, that's just not my character. Okay,
I am telling you that I am taking a break from from all of this,
okay? I'm taking a breather from all of this. I know that it
was not something that I agreed with. Okay? Obviously, y'all
know where the hell I'm at. You know, like what the [__]
I am and what I stand for and everything. So, I am taking the
time and I am distancing myself. Okay? I am distancing myself.
Okay? It is also a white woman's place to educate other white
women. Quite literally. Exactly. [laughter] And that was kind
of a conversation that
was had privately.
>> we all know that whites only listen to other whites.
So it's a white woman's place to educate other white women on
how bad it is to be white.
Thank you. Thank you. This is kind of what that's like. She's
basically sitting in like a shark cage and she's hoping that
like like the sharks are ramming the cage. She keeps throwing
out bits of chum being like, I hope that's enough. I hope that's
enough. And they keep ramming the cage. She's like, "Come on,
go away. Go away. Go away, sharks." And they're not going away.
>> Literally just just happened two days ago. I wanted
to take a breather. I wanted to process it. I watched it back
yeah, it's just I just am simply
taking a break. Taking a [__] break. Taking a breather.
Taking a break.
That's it. Um, just as just as far as like just I I need to touch
grass. I need to hang out with the people in my life that have
been there before any of this happened like before any of this
any of this fame or stream or like that's it. I just need to
go back to my roots for a little bit. Okay. And I am going to
be taking I was going to take a break regardless. I was going
to take a break regardless because um after my party I was going
to take a few days off anyway. Um and but this is basically I'm
I'm just kind of saying that I'm going to be taking a break starting
after this. Um I'm not going to stream Tuesday. Uh, so I'm going
to >> Jesus Christ. >> Take at least a week off.
>> Oh, by the way, I forgot to point out, guys. I just
saw this. Okay. Apparently, the Senate just said you to Trump.
All right. As of yesterday, the Senate was like, "Hey, guess
what? You don't get to just tariff Canada. [__] you.
You love to see it." >> Um, yeah. So,
um,
just need to take a breather. Just need to take a breather. This
month has been just freaking bananas for a lot of people. It's
been over here. I don't know what the hell is in the in the air
this month, but no, the party is happening. I'm not canceling
my party. My party is still going to happen, and I know that
the people that love me and [__] with me are going
to be there, and >> Okay, honestly, I'm I'm kind of done
with this person. I don't know how much more of this VOD there
could possibly
This was like Okay,
I'm I'm thinking in the Okay, so the for the supporter call,
we're probably going to do Tactical Templar. I'll look through
that stuff. We'll do Tactical Templar and then maybe if we have
time possibly the first episode of the Far Show or the Myin Sneak
Debate, whichever one we like more. All right,
so yeah, guys, again, the link is pinned. patreon.com/jcl.
You have to join the Discord. Patreon gives you like examples
of how to join the Discord. It tells you how to go do that. All
right, probably 5 minutes or so. I'm just going to grab some
food, use the bathroom, grab a drink, all this stuff, and I'll
be right back. And then I'll be in the channel. If you see it,
you'll see it in the Discord. You'll have your your permissions
to join the channel and we'll we'll see what's up.
All right.
Okay. Okay. All right. We'll talk to you guys later. >> See
you in the Discord shortly. Bye-bye.